OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE MEDINA AND
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON HIGHER EDUCATION. WELCOME TO
THE OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WHETHER YOU ARE HERE IN PERSON
WATCHING VIRTUALLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BURKE DISSIPATION. PLEASE
NOTE THAT ALL MATERIALS FOR THIS
HEARING CAN BE ACCESSED ONLINE
AT. ASSEMBLY DOT C. EIGHT DOT
GOV SLASH HEARINGS TO START
EXTEND A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE STAFF THAT HAVE MADE.
THIS POSSIBLE- ARE HEARING TODAY
I WILL NOT GO OVER SOME KEY
ELEMENTS OF THE STRUCTURE OF
TODAY'S OVERSIGHT HEARING.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WHILE MASSACRE
NOT REQUIRED WE SUGGEST THAT
THEY BE WARRANT WHEN NOT
ADDRESSING THE COMMITTEE.
FURTHERMORE WHILE PHYSICAL
DISTINCT SCENE IS NO LONGER
REQUIRED WE DO SUGGEST THAT
EVERYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM-
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING. WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR BY TELEPHONE.
WHEN WE REACH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THE AGENDA I WOULD
ASK THAT ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM PLEASE
APPROACH THE MIKE AND FORMALIZE.
I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING WHAT YOU FINISHED
TESTIFYING FOR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. WE WILL ALSO BE USING THE
AT&T MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A TOPIC PRESENTED
TODAY. THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT
DELAY SO I ASKED THE ALL
INVOLVED REMAIN PATIENT. THE
pHEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESSIBLE CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. YOU CAN FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. ASSEMBLY DOT
CALIFORNIA DOT GOV AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV OR MONITOR SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE BE SURE TO
MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. WITNESSES WHO ARE
UNABLE TO PHYSICALLY ATTEND THE
HEARING TODAY CAN SUBMIT WRITTEN
CONTEXT COMMENTS THE LEGISLATIVE
PORTAL PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TRANSMITTED IS
CONSIDERED A PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAY BE READ INTO THE RECORD. FOR
PANELISTS SOME OF OUR PANELISTS
HAVE ELECTED TO TESTIFY REMOTELY
AND WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
THAT MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM THE HEARING
ROOM AND ASK QUESTIONS. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS DURING
THIS HIS HEARING PLEASE CONTACT
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION AT. NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE THREE NINE SIX SO AND
THE STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. PLEASE NOTE THAT THIS
HEARING WILL ADJOURN AT FIVE
O'CLOCK. SO THANK YOU AGAIN ALL
OF YOU- COLLEAGUES- FACULTY
MEMBERS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
FOR BEING HERE AT THIS HEARING
TODAY- THE TOPIC OF THIS HEARING
IS ETHNIC STUDIES AND TEACHER
PREPARATION- TWO TOPICS THAT
THAT ARE VERY CLOSE AND DEAR TO
ME- IMPASSES THE PASSAGE OF AB
ONE OH ONE- MAKES ETHNIC STUDIES
A GRADUATION REQUIREMENT. OF IN
THE YEAR TWENTY NINE THIRTY FOR
THOSE GRADUATING IN THAT YEAR.
FOR ETHNIC STUDIES TO BE
EFFECTIVE FOR ETHNIC STUDIES-
DOING WHAT IT IS SET OUT TO DO.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT TEACHERS TEACHING AT
TEACHING THESE CLASSES AND
TEACHERS THAT ARE WELL GROUNDED
. IN IN THE HISTORY CULTURE. IN
IN THEIR WITH THEIR GONNA TEACH
AS I LEARNED IN STUDENT TEACHING
YOU CAN'T TEACH WHAT YOU DON'T
KNOW. AND SO THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HEARING IS TO FIND OUT WHAT IS
UC AND CSU DOING NOW SO THAT WE
CAN PREPARE AND BE READY WHEN IT
BECOMES A HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT. WE KNOW THE POWER
OF ETHNIC STUDIES WE HAVE SEEN
THAT TIME AND TIME AGAIN I SAW
THAT IN MY OWN CLASSROOM. THAT
ETHNIC STUDIES WHETHER UP BEACH
GHANA STUDIES BLACK STUDIES
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDIES TRANSFORM
STUDENTS. BUT IT DOES SO WHEN
THE TEACHER IN THE CLASSROOM
BELIEVES IN WHAT HE OR SHE IS
DOING. AND HAS THE KNOWLEDGE A
TO TEACH THAT CLASS AND WE ALSO
WANT TEACHERS THAT ARE
PASSIONATE. AND WITH THAT I
WILL- NOW EXTENDS FIRST TO MY
COLLEAGUE MR SANTIAGO FOR
OPENING REMARKS. AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR FOR A LOT
OF- MARCH HERE BUT ALSO FOR
HOLDING THIS IS OFTENTIMES WHEN
WE- WORK REALLY HARD TO GET
LEGISLATION THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION THE THING THAT
MAKES OR BREAKS. AND ON
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IMPORTANT I
DON'T THINK IT SHOULD BE ONLY
MEETING I THINK WE SHOULD DO
THIS OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS NOT
JUST NOT JUST ON THE DEVELOPMENT
OF TEACHERS- THE OVERSIGHT OF
CURRICULUM AND ENSURING THAT THE
OUTCOME- SAID IN THE BILL ARE
ACTUALLY- ARE ACTUALLY SHOWN. ON
IT HAVING THE ABILITY TO DO
ETHNIC STATUS AND OTHER SPEAK
FROM THE HEART FROM MY OWN
EXPERIENCES WITH A COMPLETE GAME
CHANGER THIS WASN'T AVAILABLE
SOMETHING- THAT I HAD WHEN I WAS
IN HIGH SCHOOL. AND IN FACT WAS
QUITE THE OPPOSITE WE WERE
TAUGHT A DEALER SO HISTORY I AM
ALWAYS WE SHOULD BE HISTORY
THERE'S A DIFFERENT SORT OF- NEW
WHO YOUR AS A PEOPLE AND FINDING
A POWER WERE OTHER DON'T- THE IN
A EXPERIENCE FOR EXAMPLE. YOUR
ONE VERSE OF HISTORY THAT TAKE A
LOOK AT. IMMIGRATION PATTERNS
AND USE. OF FORCE THAT WE THE
NORTH THE LIFE ILLEGAL-
IMMIGRANTS. BUT THE ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND THE AND HOW MEANT THE
PEOPLE TO COME HERE TO MAKE A
LIFE BETTER WHAT WE- TO THIS TO
THIS INTO THE STATE MORE OUT OF
LIFE. COMMENTED TO CHANGE FOR I
HAD THE BENEFIT THE HOWEVER. AND
HOW THEY ARE GOING TO SPEND- OF
WHICH GAVE ME THE BILL UNDER
WHERE HE'S IS AND QUITE FRANKLY
THEY WHAT MAY ME TO WANT TO. I
DON'T WANT TO DO SOMETHING. THAT
WAS MORE THAN JUST. ALL IT WHICH
WAS THE GOAL TO OUR NAY A
CHANGE. CHANGE THE THAT WERE
THERE BUT THAT HAPPEN TO IT WAS
IN THE THERE WAS A INSTRUCTOR
WHO TOOK THE TIME TO SHOW ME
THAT THERE WAS A DIFFERENT
HISTORY- TO WHO MY PEOPLE WERE
AND WHAT WE DID AND HOW WE
BECAME EMPOWER. I CAN'T
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH OF A GAME
CHANGER IT IS TO HAVE ETHNIC
STUDIES IT AND I THINK WE'VE ALL
SAT IN THE FRONT WAYS BUT THE
ABILITY TO DO THIS IN HIGH
SCHOOL DETERMINES OUR ABILITY TO
CHOOSE WHAT WE WANT TO DO IN
COLLEGE WILL OUR CAREER PATHS
WHAT WE CONTRIBUTE BACKTRACKING
MEANS NOT TO SAY THAT WE DON'T
IF WE DON'T DO THIS. BUT I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE ETHNIC STUDIES AND THAT
IS A REQUIREMENT THAT DAY AND
THAT WE GET EMPOWERMENT FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO WE ARE OUR HISTORY IN
WHO WE BECOME OUR CULTURE. THAT
AIM KEY TO THAT IS GOING TO HAVE
THE INSTRUCTOR SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING IN HAPPENING THAT
ROBUST CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING AT THE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF HIGHER EDUCATION. TO
GO TO CREATE THAT INSTRUCTOR
THAT TEACHER AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL- OR OTHERWISE WHO WHO'S
GOING TO HELP TEACH THOSE MINES
ABOUT OUR PEOPLE'S HISTORY THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL BECAUSE
IF WE DON'T DO THIS RIGHT IF WE
DON'T DO THIS RIGHT. THE THINGS
WE SET OUT TO DO IN THE BILL I
SAY WE BECAUSE I THINK EVERYBODY
SHARED THAT SAME PASSION THAT
YOU LET IF WE DON'T GET THIS
RIGHT. WE WILL HAVE MISSED IN
OUR- A HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO
EMPOWER PEOPLE WHICH IS WHAT
THIS BILL TRIED TO DO NOT JUST
EDUCATORS IT'S A BILL OF
EMPOWERMENT THAT HELPS TO CHANGE
LIVES COMMUNITIES AND PRODUCE
THE NEXT THE NEXT- LEADERSHIP-
IN CALIFORNIA BE IT AT IN THE
CORPORATE LEVEL BE IT IN
INSTITUTIONS OR EVEN HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE'VE GOT TO GET
THIS RIGHT. AND SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ISSUES IS ACTUALLY CRITICAL. AB
THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO DR CHOI IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GIVE OPENING
REMARKS. THANK YOU CHAIR I AM
ALSO EXCITED ABOUT THIS- PROCESS
AT THE NEXT THIRTY IS- BEING
REQUIRED- AT THE SECONDARY LEVEL
SCHOOL RISA. I COME FROM SOUTH
KOREA REGIONALLY- I WILL COUNTRY
WAS BRAGGING- HOW OUR SOUTH
KOREA WAS A MADE UP OF LAW. IT
DOES SO WITHOUT- ONE PEOPLE. AND
NOW- THE SITUATION IS-CHANGING
I THINK GOAL OVER THE WORD-
ECONOMY REQUIRES- PAPER TO MOVE
AROUND. NOW MANY DIFFERENT
ETHNIC GROUPS ARE ARE MOVING TO
KOREA- AND- THEY BECOME A GOOD
WORKFORCE. HAVING IMMIGRATED TO
THIS COUNTRY- IN MY ADULT LIFE-
I SUDDENLY- I FOUND A DIFFERENT
WORD. THIS COUNTRY WAS- KNOCKED
OUT MONO ETHNIC COUNTRY MADE UP
OF ALL THESE DIFFERENT- PEOPLE
WITH A DIFFERENT ETHNIC
BACKGROUND AND LANGUAGE BACK ON
THE COUCH OR BACKGROUND. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS COUNTRY HAD
TO GO THROUGH- IN TONER-
PROCESS- THROUGH A CIVIL WAR AND
THE STEELERS CB IT RIGHT SO ARE
NOT TOTALLY- A RESULT THE
MATTERS IT I THINK A CELLPHONE.
ISSUE AND THE MANY- SOCIAL
PROBLEMS ARE BEING PRESENTED TO-
ISSUE WE HAVE SEEN IT FOR NO
REASON THE YEARS. AND EVEN
THOUGH- KOREAN COMMUNITY HAVE%
SUFFERED. I THINK BUSINESSES-
HAVE A SEPARATE THEM MOST- FOR
VARIOUS REASONS NOW DURIG THE
LA RIOTS. AND THE NAM OF KOREAN
COMMUNITY IS SO REALIZING THAT
THE HOW WE CAN- EXPO- SO OF A
KOREAN PEOPLE TO BOTH THE-
DIFFERENT NOT GROUPS OF PEOPLE
AND TO CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT.
IN OUR COMMUNITY MORE ARE
AVAILABLE OUR COMMUNITY IN PEACE
AND HARMONY OR THE DIFFERENT
ETHNIC GROUPS. AND A TEACHING
OUR DIFFERENCES IN THE
BACKGROUND- THROUGH THE HIGH
SCHOOL. AND THE- I THINK THIS IS
A EXCELLENT IDEA BUT IT'LL BE A
LOT OF WHAT CHALLENGES BECAUSE
THIS IS A NOT ONE TWO OR THREE
OR FOUR DIFFERENT KINDS OF-
ETHNIC ETHNICITY WE ARE DEALING
WITH THAT. I BET. INTERVIEW OVER
ONE HUNDRED DIFFERENT KINDS SELF
LAW A DIFFERENT CULTURES AND A-
ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS- BECAUSE I DO
KNOW THAT THAT. COMING FROM CITY
OF IRVINE- EVEN THOUGH IT
APPEARS TO BE A WHITE COMMUNITY
IN FACT- IT IS NOT THE WHEN
IRVINE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
I. HAVE DONE- SURVEY AND THEN I
THINK THAT THEY UPDATE THAT THE
SURVEY CONTINUES TO THE- WHAT
THE MOTHER LANGUAGES DO YOU
SPEAK AT HOME. THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND I THINK
IT'S A NEARLY SEVENTY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES ARE BEING SPOKEN AT
HOMES. YOU CAN SEE OF THE
WORKABLE CULTURES AND ETHNIC
BACKGROUND. THE S. C. IS A MADE
UP. THINK OF WHAT THE UNITED
STATES THINK OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HOW MANY DIFFERENT
CULTURES SO WE ARE DEALING WITH
WHAT KIND OF PEOPLE ARE LIVING
IN THE STATE. SO EXPECT TO SEE
DIFFERENT THIS KIND OF WHAT
DIFFERENCE IS- AND THOUGH FOR
THEM TO UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
BACKGROUND THAT THEIR
CONTRIBUTION IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THAT OUR DIFFERENCES AND THEN
ALSO BEAUTIFUL CULTURES THAT
THEY BRING IN IN EARLY HF DURING
THE HIGH SCHOOL TIME SO HOW WE
CAN SEGMENT WITH A THERAPY ONE
SEMESTER ONE NEAR WE NEED TO
FIGURE THAT OUT THAT AND THE
WHAT PORTION HOW WE CAN SLICE
THE TIME. AND THE TEACH ENOUGH-
CURRICULUM- ENOUGH THE CONTENT
BELONGING TO THAT THE PARTICULAR
ISSUES BECAUSE I DO SEE HERE
WHAT IS ETHNIC STUDIES STUFF FOR
FUNDAMENTAL DISCIPLINES OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN BACKGROUND-
CHICANOS SOURCE TO THAT
FILIPINOS NATIVE AMERICANS ASIAN
AMERICAN SLASH IN THE PACIFIC
ISLANDERS I'M SURE THERE ARE SO
THOSE ARE MENTIONED HERE AND THE
KOREAN COMMUNITY. IN LOS ANGELES
TEACHERS HAVE BEEN SO EXCITED-
EVER SINCE OF THIS BILL WILL
ALSO INTRODUCED A AND THE
PARTICULARLY. AFTER YOU'VE
PASSED THE- IN INVOLVED. IS SO
OTHER ON AND IN PERSON- PREP. BY
A KOREAN EDUCATORS TO COME UP
WITH US TO DEVELOP THE MODERATE
CURRICULA EVEN IN BOARDING OUR
SUPERINTENDENT- SOMEONE AND HE
WAS ALSO INVOLVED IN AN ONLINE
DISCUSSION EVEN NOT A MONTH AGO
WE MET THEY AND THEY LAY AND
THAT THEY ARE SO EXCITED OF WHAT
THE MODERN CURRICULUM WHAT
ISSUES. AT THE WHAT THE
INDIVIDUAL OR SO WHAT
CONTRIBUTIONS SO THAT ASIAN
AMERICANS BUT IN PARTICULAR
KOREAN AMERICANS HAVE MADE IN
THIS COUNTRY SO TRYING TO COME
UP WITH THE AMOUNT OF CURRICULUM
TO FIT INTO THAT THE SEGMENT OF
TIME THAT MAY BE LOCATED ON.
FOOD TO LEARN ABOUT THE ASIAN
CULTURE AND- PARTICULAR- KOREAN
AMERICAN CONTRIBUTIONS OF ALL
KOREAN COACHES SO I'M SURE THIS
KIND OF A WORKER WOULD BE QUITE
LONG- AMONG MANY DIFFERENT
ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS I HOPE WHAT
THEY DO TRY T COME UP HIM UP.
WHAT IN. I LOVE. WE CAN TEACH.
ONCE THOSE SHOT X. TO TYPICAL
IMPORT THE HIGH. ISSUE SO OF
THIS ETHNIC. THEN THINK THAT
THEY WERE ON TO BETTER AND- WHEN
SOMEONE YOU COME FROM THIS
CULTURE AND THIS BACKGROUND AND
THAT THEY ARE MORE CURIOUS AND
THAT THEY WILL UNLIKELY TO
BECOME MORE FRIENDS. AND THEN
WHEN THEY ARE INTERESTED ENOUGH
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN- PICK AND
CHOOSE- A HORDE- MAJORIE CANDY-
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES ALL
ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES SO IT
HISPANIC STUDIES THAT YOU CAN BE
THEIR OWN. IN ALL OF COLLEGE
MAJOR. AND I IN FACT I
INTRODUCED OF KOREAN CULTURE
FESTIVAL. TEN YEARS AGO WHEN I
WAS SO CONCERNED MEMBER THERE.
AND A WIN TROUPE OF THE KOREAN
I'M SYMBOL ELECTED THAT THE CITY
NEAR. TO THE COUNSELOR. R. O.
FIVE US OF PLUS. AND THE ORANGE
COUNTY RED IS KNOWING THE
PRODUCT KOREANS ARE KOREAN HAVE
. I DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER THAT WAS
A POSITIVE STATEMENT THE HOT
WHENEVER I DO A STATE. AND THE
FLIPPING OVER HER ENTIRE STORY
ABOUT US- AND THEN IWAS AFRAID
THE- ENGINE OWNED OUT ON THE
FLOOR I TRY TO CELEBRATE THE
KOREAN AMERICAN DAY JANUARY
FIFTH- THIRTEENTH THE- AND- THE
PURPOSE OF THAT THE- FESTIVAL
WAS SHOCKED. CEREMONY FIVE
MINNESOTA MANY PHOTO
OPPORTUNITIES CONGRATULATIONS
THAT DIDN'T MEAN ANYTHING SO I'M
GOING TO HAPPEN FOR YOU DALY
COACH WATER FESTIVAL FOR ALL THE
CITIZENS OF IRVINE COME OUT
DURING THE VISIT TO COME OUT AND
ENJOY IT LEARN ABOUT THE- TASTE
SYSTEM KIMCHI- APPROVAL HE OR OR
OR OR A K. POP WELL- BTS
HOMEWORK KERN NUMB STYLE OR
WHATEVER. THEY CAN THEY CAN IN
ALL FIELDS AND EXPERIENCE SO
THAT THE WHEN THEY UNDERSTAND
THE MOST LIKELY THEY WOULD
BECOME A FRIEND SAYS THAT'S THE
REASON IT IS BUT THIS YEAR WE
ARE. AFTER STOPPING TWO YEARS
SAID THIS YEAR- WE ARE RESUMING
FOR ELEVEN THIRTY YEARS
CELEBRATION I THINK THAT IS- AN
EXAMPLE I WANT TO INTRODUCE SO
HOPEFULLY THIS ETHNIC STUDIES WE
EXPLORED. ALL DIFFERENT KINDS
SHOULD ANSWER. DIFFERENT
CULTURES SO I THINK THIS IS A
HEALTHY WEIGHT- ARE SO
REPUBLICAN IT WAS A VERY
DIFFICULT. FOR ME TO VOTE ON
THAT I THINK I BELIEVE I WAS THE
ONLY REPUBLICAN DEFYING THE
RECOMMENDED THE BOOK THAT. FOR
YOU I GOT UP TO A LOT. HEY ARE
YOU VOTE FORCE R. T. WHAT I BOOK
FOR R. T. I LOOKED UP I COULDN'T
FIND THIS YEAR IF YOU WERE.
THERE. AND ALLOW YOU. ASKED HOME
IT WAS A CRITICAL. WAS GOING TO
ON. SO I THINK THROUGH THE KIND
OF A HEARING CAN CUT. AND- BUT
UP SOME ISSUE AT THIS IS A GOOD
THE STEP OF WILL HAVE IN. THANK
TO SHOW. THANK YOU DON'T. THANK
YOU TO JOY- THE MAY REMIND MY
COLLEAGUE THAT WE WERE LOOKING
FOR BRIEF OPENING LIKE ARAMBULA. DR WEBER. WELL I WILL THAT BE
PRE- I AM VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE'RE HAVING TODAY- ETHNIC
CITIES IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT-
AS MY COLLEAGUE- MIGUEL SANTIAGO
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
THIS IN SCHOOLS GROWING UP HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND I WAS LUCKY
THAT I HAD A PARENT WHO- IS VERY
FAMILIAR AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
HISTORY- AND SO THAT SHE COULD
IMPART THAT KNOWLEDGE ON ME AND
MY BROTHERS BUT YOU KNOW NOW
THAT I HAVE TWO LITTLE ONES OF
MY OWN AND THAT'S NOT MY
BACKGROUND BUT I'M TRYING TO
TEACH THEM ABOUT OUR HISTORY.
IT'S NOT AS EASY AS ONE WOULD
THINK AND SO IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT ONLY HAVE
THIS IN THEIR IN THEIR
CURRICULUM THAT WE DO IT RIGHT
AND WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
TEACHERS THAT ARE TEACHING THIS
ARE EDUCATED THEMSELVES THAT WE
DON'T JUST SAY REGULAR SCIENCE
INSTRUCTOR CAN REGULAR HISTORY
INSTRUCTOR CAN DO IT YOU MUST
UNDERSTAND ETHNIC STUDIES MUST
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCES SO THAT
YOU CAN TEACH IT TO THE STUDENTS
BUT ALSO TO THE OTHER TEACHER-
IT DOES HELP DEVELOP A SENSE OF
APPRECIATION AND RESPECT AND I
REMEMBER GROWING UP. YOU KNOW
THERE WAS THIS- BELIEVE THAT YOU
KNOW BLACK PEOPLE JUST WEREN'T
GOOD IN MATH YOU KNOW BLACK KIDS
JUST AREN'T GOOD IN MATH AND
SCIENCE BUT THEN WHEN WE LOOK AT
OUR HISTORY AND WE LEARN ABOUT
PEOPLE LIKE KATHERINE JOHNSON
AND REALIZE THAT WE WOULD NOT
HAVE GONE TO THE MOON HAD IT NOT
BEEN FOR. BOOKS MATHEMATICIANS
JUST OF HOW MANY FOR TWENTY WE
CAN HAVE NEW THAT AND WE WEREN'T
AT THAT TIME STEREO TYPE PRINT
ORDER YOU KNOW PUT A BOX AROUND
WHAT WE AS A PEOPLE WE'RE GOOD
AT AND WHAT WE ARE AT. NO THING
UP LEARNING ALLOWS FOR TOLERANCE
ALLOWS FOR YOU TO REALIZE THAT
YOU'RE A TWO ENTITIES ARE
LIMITLESS AND SO I AM VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE TODAY
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO US
GETTING THIS. RIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT IT CAN BE A
BLUE PRINT FOR THE REST OF THE
NIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
WEBER MR LEFT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- AND MR VICE
CHAIR. FIRST OF ALL I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPORTANT WORK
OF THIS BODY AND THE MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY SPECIFICALLY
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE PUSHED FOR
THIS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS WITH
RESPECT TO A LEGACY AND I WANT
TO COMMEND THE CHAIR FOR HELPING
TO CONVENE US IN ACTUALLY
GETTING THE JOB DONE. TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE A BLUEPRINT FOR NOT
JUST FOR CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THE
COUNTRY. IT IS. THE WORST KEPT
SECRET THAT THERE ARE. SOME DEEP
DIVISIONS IN OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
STATE. AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS
THAT AS WE HOPE TO RECTIFY THE
INJUSTICES. THAT WE LEARN ABOUT
OUR OWN HISTORY. AND SIMILARLY
TO. HEAR FROM THE VERY
PASSIONATE WORDS OF THE
REPUBLICAN VICE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWING THAT THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE. THAT WE ARE
STRONGER WE KNOW ABOUT OUR OWN
HISTORY. AND BEING A FOURTH
GENERATION CALIFORNIAN SPEAKING
MORE SPANISH THAN I DO CHINESE.
AND ALSO FEELING LIKE A
PERPETUAL FOREIGNER IN MY OWN
COUNTRY. I WISH THAT I HAD
ETHNIC STUDIES AS A STUDENT.
THAT I WAS INFORMED ABOUT THE
STRUGGLES AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST MY OWN BUT
WE SHARED BY A NUMBER OF OTHER
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. AS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE LIVED IN
SHARED EXPERIENCES. OF THE
WOMEN'S RIGHTS MOVEMENT OF.
THOSE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
LATINO FARMWORKER MOVEMENT WHICH
IS ALSO ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER.
LEADING US TO. THE RIGHT OF
. THAT WE CAN'T EVEN SAY THE
WORD GAY ANYMORE IN SOME STATES
- THIS IS ABOUT BASIC
FUNDAMENTALS OF HUMANITY. AND
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF BASIC HUMANITY
THAT WE MUST LOVE ONE ANOTHER.
AND THAT WE MUST BUILD A
COALITION TO UPLIFT EACH OTHER.
BUT WE DON'T. HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IF WE DON'T KNOW OUR
OWN HISTORY. AND SO. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON OUR
VALUES AGAIN COMMEND OUR
COMMITTEE CHAIR. FOR YOUR
STEWARDSHIP IN HELPING TO ENSURE
THAT ALL VOICES ARE HERE. AND
ONE FINAL POINT. ASSEMBLY EMBER
MEDINA HAS MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT HE WANTS TO ENSURE ALL
VOICES AT THE TABLE AND AS VICE
CHAIR OF H. PROVIDER CAUCUS IN
THIS CHAIR THE LGBT CAUCUS I
KNOW YOU HAVE CONVENE TO VARIOUS
CAUCUSES. HELPING ENSURE THAT
ALL OF OUR VOICES ARE AT THE
TABLE AS DIFFICULT AS IT MIGHT
BE BECAUSE IF WE'RE NOT HAVING
CONVERSATIONS IN THIS BODY ABOUT
HOW WE SHARE POWER HOW WE TALK
ABOUT RACE HOW TO RESPECT OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO BE ABLE
TO. DO SO. THIS IS AN
AFFIRMATION FOR US TO CONTINUE
THESE. DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS.
BUT TO DO IT WITH A SENSE OF
GRACE. AND LOVE. AND RESPECT FOR
EACH OTHER'S CULTURES AND
BUILDING UNDERSTANDING SO I'M
JUST INCREDIBLY PROUD. OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT HERE AND TO
BE PART OF THIS CONVERSATION. AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR LOW
MR GABRIEL. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN- APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE OVER
MANY YEARS- AND I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE DOING- THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING TALK ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BECAUSE-
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE KIND OF DIVERSE PLURALISTIC
MULTI ETHNIC DEMOCRACY. THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO BE HONEST
ABOUT OUR HISTORY AND WE NEED TO
TEACH OUR HISTORY THAT IS
PROBABLY REFLECTIVE OF ALL
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK BACK TO
THE HISTORY THAT I LEARNED. AS A
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENT
FOR MY ENTIRE LIFE. THINKING
ABOUT FOURTH GRADE WHEN I
LEARNED ABOUT OUR INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY WRITING YOU WOULD BE
BUILT A MISSION OUT OF SUGAR
CUBES IN YOU. WHITEWASH
EVERYTHING ELSE. IT WASN'T UNTIL
LATER IN LIFE TAT I REALLY
UNDERSTOOD THE TRUE HISTORY OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
RELEASE TARGET TO THIS COMMUNITY
KNOW. THAT FOR THE SAME FOR THE
LATINO COMMUNITY AND THE BLACK
COMMUNITY AND THE ANTI COMMUNITY
AND SO MANY OTHER COMMUNITIES.
FAIL TO SEE THEMSELVES REFLECTED
IN OUR HISTORY. AND WE GLOSSED
OVER- OR DIDN'T TALK ABOUT A LOT
OF THE MOST COMPLICATED AND
DIFFICULT PARTS OF OUR HISTORY
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. THE
STRONG MULTI ETHNIC DEMOCRACY
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE. WE HAVE TO
OF ETHNIC STUDIES AND WE HAVE TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE
TO OPEN PEOPLE'S HEARTS AND
MINDS- IF PEOPLE HAVE TO SEE
THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN THE
HISTORY BOOK. YOU KNOW AT THE
SAME TIME I DO YOU THINK THAT
THE NUANCES REALLY IMPORTANT
HERE. THIS HAS BEEN A
COMPLICATED CONVERSATION AS
WE'VE GONE HERE WE THERE WERE
CERTAINLY COMPLICATED
CONVERSATIONS AROUND. THE MODEL
CURRICULUM- AND I REMEMBER A-
VERY POWERFUL CONVERSATION I HAD
WITH THE OTHER DOCTOR WEBER. I'M
NOT THE ONE THAT I PRIVILEGE TO
SIT NEXT TO. NOW ABOUT HOW
ETHNIC STUDIES DONE RIGHT CAN BE
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL. STUDIES
DONE WRONG WHEN YOU DON'T GET
THE DETAILS RIGHT- CAN BE VERY
DIVISIVE. AND CAN CAUSE- CAN
CAUSE A LOT OF PROBLEMS AND SO.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
ABOUT YOU KNOW WE AS A
LEGISLATURE TO WANT TO THANK-
ARE. A MY COLLEAGUE HERE FOR HIS
FOR HIS COMMENTS AND FOR HIS
AFFIRMATION. YOU KNOW WE I THINK
HAVE TRY TO CHART A COURSE HERE
AND THE- INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION IS ON THE SAME OF AN
ETHNIC STUDIES THAT IS BROADLY
INCLUSIVE- THAT DOESN'T PROMOTE
BIGOTRY OR DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST ANY GROUP OF STUDENTS IN
THE CLASS- AND WE BUILT A-
REALLY STRONG GUARD. TO ME DO WE
DO THAT SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING ABOUT THAT- I AM
FIRMLY OF THE BELIEF THAT WE CAN
HAVE. A STRONG. POWERFUL NINETY
OPENING EDGY ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM. BUT DO THAT IN A WAY
IN WHICH- YOU KNOW NO COMMUNITY
HERE FEELS TARGETED AND SO. I
THINK GETTING INTO THE NEW WANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE DETAILS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I LOOK FOR
TO THAT CONVERSATION TODAY SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL. THANK YOU AGAIN TO ALL
MY COLLEAGUES FROM TAKING THE
TIME. TO I AGREE WITH YOU. WHAT
IS VERY IMPORTANT MOVING
FORWARD. AND THAT IS THAT WE
HAVE. A TEACHING FORCE. THAT
KNOWS. WHAT THEY'RE TEACHING.
AND IT IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER IT. IN A POWERFUL WAY SO
THAT IT REMAINS WHAT IT'S BEEN-
OVER TIME. AND WITH THAT I'M
GONNA CALL THE FIRST PANEL. OF
FORWARD. OR AT LEAST THOSE WHO
ARE HERE. DR MIKE TORRANCE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- IT WILL BE. ON THE
SCREEN- DIRECTOR OF CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS AND INSTRUCTIONAL
RESOURCES AND ERIN SCREWBALL AND
THE GOOD FROM THE COMMISSION OF
TEACHER CREDENTIALING DIRECTOR
OF CERTIFICATION WILL ALSO BE
VIA- INTERNET THE WEB AND THEN
DOCTOR- DAVID DID WIRED DIRECTOR
OF PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
DIVISION SO HOPEFULLY THEY ARE
THERE- DR MIKE TOWARDS WILL BE
THERE TO BEGIN THE PAL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DR MIKE
FLORES DIRECTOR OF THE
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS IN
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES DIVISION
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK ON THE TOPIC
OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
WITH A BRIEF STATEMENT ABOUT
ELATION SHIP A STANDARD.
CONTRACT PARTS TOMORROW
CURRICULA AND INSTRUCTIONAL
RESOURCES JUST TO SET THE STAGE
THE STANDARDS ARE WHAT WE WANT
OUR STUDENTS TO KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND AND BE ABLE TO DO BY
THE END OF EVERY GRADE LEVEL SO
FOR TEACHERS THAT. THE WHITE FOR
INSTRUCTION CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS ON THE OTHER HAND
PROVIDING INSTRUCTIONAL GUIDANCE
FOR EDUCATORS ON HOW TO DESIGN.
STANDARDS CURRICULUM.
IMPLEMENTED THAT CURRICULA- HIGH
QUALITY INSTRUCTION TO SUPPORT
ALL OF THAT INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS ARE THE TOOLS SUCH AS
BOOKS AND LEARNING MATERIALS IN
A LOT OF PEOPLE MIGHT NOT. IT'S
THE- GAINES DECISION AND
SELECTING THE AFFECT TEACHING.
THAT LEADS US TO MASS OF THE
CONTENT STANDARDS NOW THE MODEL
CURRICULUM THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY OR- THE ETHNIC
STUDIES IS A GUIDANCE DOCUMENT
THAT PROVIDES SUPPORT TO
TEACHERS AND LEADERS IN HELPING
THE COURSES AND OR DIRECTION
CONTENT IN A SPECIFIC TOPIC AREA
SO IT'S NOT A COMPLETE CLASSROOM
CURRICULUM OR SET OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS RATHER
IT'S INTENDED AS- FOCUSED. LIKE
TO TRANSITION TO THE ETHNIC
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM ITSELF-
AS YOU INDICATED THAT MODEL
CURRICULUM WAS ADOPTED BY THE
STATE BOARD ON MARCH EIGHTEENTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE MODEL
CURRICULUM WAS DEVELOPED BROADLY
AS INTENDED TARGETS THAT ALLOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO. CARPORT THE
PEOPLE DEMOCRATS SPECIFICALLY IN
THEIR COMMUNITY TO THE STUDENTS
SITTING IN THOSE TWO THE AT THE
STUDIES MARK MISS GAME THAT
EMPOWERING STUDENTS BY
ELIMINATING THE OFTEN UNTOLD
STRUGGLES AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THE FOUR GROUPS ACTUAL STUDIES
THAT MIGHT SURE IN TROUBLE DO
YOU TO. STATE GROUP THE TWO.
NATIONAL ETHNIC STUDIES FOR TO
STAB INTEL HIGHER EDUCATION THE
FOCUS ON THOSE FOR GROUP FROM AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS. TWO
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF THESE
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
PEOPLE'S WHO HAVE OFTEN BEEN
UNTOLD IN U. S. HISTORY COURSES
HOWEVER IT IS UNDERSTOOD THAT
COMMUNITY HAS ITS OWN TECHNICAL
AS A VICE CHURCH PRIEST BURKE OF
ANY AGE DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP IS
IT'S OWN UNIQUE THREE TROUBLES
IN CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE SO
THEREFORE THE MOP BREAKING
SPORTS LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES THE FLEXIBILITY. TO
ADAPT THE CORRECT ADDRESS THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND DIVERSITY THERE
JUST AS CHEAP EIGHT AB ONE ONE
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW CREATING THE
ETHNIC STUDIES GRAY PART. HE WON
AT COMPLETE ONE COURSE IN NEXT.
TO HIGH SCHOOL. AND STARTING
WITH COUPONS FOR AND TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SCHOOL YEAR AND IN ORDER
TO MEET THAT DEADLINE SCHOOLS IN
JUST FIRST HAVE TO OFFER OF
COURSE BY THE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX YEAR. NOW THE MINIMUM COURSE
LENGTHS TO FULFILL THIS
REQUIREMENT IS ONE SEMESTER BUT
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS MAY CHOOSE
REQUIRE A FULL YEAR COURSE IN
ETHNIC STUDIES CENTERS
FLEXIBILITY IN DETERMINING HOW
STUDENT MAY SATISFY THE
REQUIREMENT INCLUDING. FORCES
BASED ON THE MODEL CURRICULUM
AND ETHNIC STUDIES THAT WAS
ADOPTED BY THE STATE BOARD. AND
EXIST PATH STUDIES COURSE
THROUGH AN ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
TAUGHT AS PART OF A COURSE THAT
HAS BEEN APPROVED AS A MEETING
ETAJIMA REQUIREMENTS. OR A
LOCALLY DEVELOPED ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSE APPROVED BY THE GOVERNING
BOARD OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT OR
THE GOVERNING BOARD OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOL SO AS FAR AS THE
QUESTION OF HOW MANY TEACHERS
ARE NEEDED TO MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT. AT THIS TIME WE
DON'T KNOW. WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
THAT ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
LONGITUDINAL PUPIL ACHIEVEMENT
DATA SYSTEM ANNUALLY OVER TWO.
FIVE HUNDRED. PUBLIC SCHOOLS
SERVE OUR HIGH SCHOOL POPULATION
SO THAT INCLUDES TRADITIONAL
HIGH SCHOOLS CONTINUATION
ALTERNATIVE COMMUNITY DAY AND K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE GRADUATING CLASS OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO HAS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS ENROLLED AS OF THE
CENSUS DAY WHICH IS THE FIRST
WEDNESDAY IN OCTOBER. SO IT'S
ENTIRELY UP TO THE AGE OF TWENTY
THIRD STUDENT RATIOS AND THE
FREQUENCY OF COURSE OFFERINGS
WITHIN THEIR LOCAL PASTOR
CATTLE. EVEN IF IT'S JUST ONE
TEACHER SCHOOL SITE THAT WOULD
MEAN TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
TEACHERS. NUMBER THAT GOES UP
FROM THERE DEPENDING ON THE
LOCAL TEACHER TO STUDENT RATIO.
ANOTHER APPROACH WOULD BE TO
ALLOW X. THE STAFF THE OPRAH.
BACK I. THE WORK CD EAST
EDUCATOR ACTS IN D'HIV WHO HAVE
BEEN AND WILL THE MILLION DOLLAR
AND LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACT TO
PROVIDE ELEAZAR WITH
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
SUPPORT THAT DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
AND EXPANDED ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES AS WELL AS CREATE AN
ONLINE PROPOSED NEXT STUDIES
STRUCTURAL RESOURCES I NEVER
WHAT WAS SUPPOSED IN MARCH CAN
FIND SANTEE COUNTY EDUCATION AS
THE ANTICIPATED CONTRACTOR
THROUGH A REQUEST FOR
APPLICATION. WE ANTICIPATE A
CONTRACTOR WILL FORM AND
FACILITATE A MONTHLY
COLLABORATION COMMITTEE THAT
WILL DEVELOP AND REVIEW
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES USED FOR
THIS PROJECT. DEVELOPING
FACILITY AT LEAST TEXT TOTAL
STATE MY PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
PROGRAMS SUCH AS COMMUNITIES OF
PRACTICE. DEVELOPING SUPPORT
SYSTEM A REGIONAL COMMUNITIES
ARE PRACTICES THAT WILL PROVIDE
LOCAL SUPPORT TO EDUCATORS IN
ELEAZAR DEVELOPING HIS NUCLEAR
AND EXPANDED ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES. PROVIDE ONGOING
CLASSROOM SUPPORT TO EDUCATORS
ADMINISTRATORS AND PARA
PROFESSIONALS IN BETWEEN
SCHEDULED STATEWIDE REGIONAL
CHANNEL COMMITTEE IT IS A
PRACTICE AND CAN SUPPORT AN
ONLINE REPOSITORY THAT PROVIDES
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THESE NEW
AND EXPANDED ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES. INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED FORCES THAT USE THE
STATE BOARD ADOPTED ETHNIC
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM NOW
THERE'S ALREADY FACE APPLICANTS
WERE ENCOURAGED TO PARTNER WITH
INSTITUTES OF HIGHER AND- TO
SUPPORT AT STUDIES PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT. IT
PARTNERSHIPS INCLUDE EXPERT IN
THE FIELD PROVIDING ONGOING
CONTENT AND INSTRUCTIONAL
GUIDANCE TO PROJECT
PARTICIPANTS. SO I DON'T WANT TO
TAKE UP ALL OF YOUR TIME SO I'LL
CONCLUDE THEIR- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU DR
TAURUS IT NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
PARENTS SCHOOL BALL COMMISSION
OF TEACHER CREDENTIALING
DIRECTOR OF THE CERTIFICATION
DIVISION. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDIA MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THAT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
ERIN SCREWBALL AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CERTIFICATES IN
DIVISION FOR THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. OUR
DIVISION OVERSEES THE EVALUATION
AND PROCESSING APPLICATIONS FOR
CREDENTIALS PERMITS CERTIFICATES
IN WAIVERS WE ALSO OVERSEE THE
ANNUAL MONITORING OF TEACHER
ASSIGNMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IS HONORED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO TALK WITH YOU
ABOUT FOR THE STATE IS DOING TO
BE PREPARED FOR THE NEW CASE
RECALL ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT. THE COMMISSION
RECOGNIZES THE VALUE THAT COMES
FROM CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SEEING
THEMSELVES IN THEIR CURRICULUM
THROUGH ETHNIC STUDIES. I WANTED
TO BEGIN FIRST BY PROVIDING SOME
BACKGROUND ON CREDENTIALING AS
IT RELATES TO ETHNIC STUDIES.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE TWO
CREDENTIALS THE AUTHORIZED A
TEACHER TO TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES. THE MULTIPLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIAL- IN THE SINGLE
SUBJECT TEACHING CREDENTIAL BOTH
OF THESE ARE GENERAL EDUCATION
TEACHING CREDENTIALS THE
AUTHORIZED SERVICE IN DIFFERENT
CLASSROOM SETTINGS. WELL SUBJECT
CREDENTIALS AUTHORIZED SERVICE
IN AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SETTING
AND ALLOW TEACHER TO TEACH ALL
CONTENT WHICH INCLUDES ETHNIC
STUDIES TO STUDENTS IN A SELF
CONTAINED CLASSROOM SETTING
WHERE THE STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING
ALL THEIR INSTRUCTION FROM A
SINGLE TEACHER THROUGHOUT THE
DAY. SINGLE SINGLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIALS ARE TYPICALLY USED
AT THE MIDDLE OR HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL AND THEY ALLOW THE TEACHER
TO TEACH AT VERY SPECIFIC
CONTENT IN A DEPARTMENT ALLIES
CLASSROOM. WHERE THE TEACHER IS
FOCUSED ON TEACHING ONLY ONE
SUBJECT IN A SINGLE CLASS PERIOD
. THE SINGLE SUBJECT CREDENTIALS
ARE EARNED BASED UPON THE
COMPLETION OF THE SUBJECT MATTER
REQUIREMENTS. IN ONE OR MORE
BROAD STATUTORY SUBJECT AREAS
IT'S LISTED AS THE CREDENTIALS
AUTHORIZATION. IS BROAD SUBJECTS
ARE ORGANIZED LIKE AN UMBRELLA
WITH RELATED SUBJECT AREAS.
WITHIN THE AUTHORIZATION
ALLOWING THE TEACHER TO TEACH
MULTIPLE INTERCONNECTED CONTENT
AREAS THROUGHOUT THEIR PRIMARY
AUTHORIZATION. SO FOR SINGLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIALS ETHNIC
STUDIES FALLS WITHIN THE BROAD
AUTHORIZATION OF SOCIAL SCIENCE
. IN ADDITION TO ETHNIC STUDIES
THE SOCIAL SCIENCE AUTHORIZATION
ALLOWS A TEACHER TO TEACH OTHER
SIMILAR CONTENT AREAS SUCH AS
ANTHROPOLOGY CONTEMPORARY ISSUES
OF CULTURAL STUDIES
INTERNATIONAL GOVERNMENT
SOCIOLOGY AND HUMANITY. ARE
CURRENTLY CLOSE TO FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND VALID AN ACTIVE SINGLE
pHAVE THE SOCIAL SCIENCE
AUTHORIZATION. EDUCATORS THAT
DID NOT INITIALLY EARNED THEIR
CREDENTIALS SOCIAL SCIENCES
ALWAYS ALSO HAVE THE OPTION OF
ADDING THE SOCIAL SCIENCES
AUTHORIZATION THROUGH THE
COMPLETION OF THE SUBJECT MATTER
REQUIREMENTS AND OF COURSE IN
THE TEACHING METHODS PERSONAL
WORK WITH SOCIAL SCIENCES. IN
ORDER TO EARN A CREDENTIAL
AUTHORIZING SOCIAL SCIENCE
TEACHER PREPARATION CANDIDATE
MUST DEMONSTRATE THE ABILITY TO
TEACH TO STATE ADOPTED CONTENT
STANDARD. BY HELPING STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND EVENTS AND PERIODS
FROM MULTIPLE PERSPECTIVES USING
PRIMARY SOURCES CULTURAL
ARTIFACTS WORKS OF ART AND
LITERATURE. THEIR PREPARATION
HOPES TO GUIDE. IN UNDERSTANDING
INSIGHTS INTO HISTORICAL PERIODS
AND CULTURES. AND DINNER
STANDINGS OF PEOPLE EVENTS AND
DEBATES TWO THEMES CONCEPTS AND
PRINCIPLES. AND RELATED SOCIAL
SCIENCE CONTENT TO BROADER
CONTEXTUAL UNDERSTANDINGS SO
THAT STUDENTS BETTER UNDERSTAND
THEIR CURRENT WORLD. BUT WHEN
I'M GOING TO TURN THIS FOR TO MY
COLLEAGUE DAVID WHO'S GOING TO
GO INTO A BIT MORE DETAIL ON THE
PREPARATION AND SUBJECT MATTER
APARTMENTS FOR TEACHERS
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED TO TEACH
ETHNIC STUDIES. EVEN BIGGER AND
MY NAME IS DAVID TO HERE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. OUR DIVISION
DEVELOP STANDARDS FOR ALL
POTENTIAL AREAS WE PROGRAMS.
OVERSEAS REQUIRED EDUCATOR
PREPARATION EXAMS AND
ASSESSMENTS. AND REVIEWS AND
ACCREDITS MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES.
AND LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
THAT OFFER EDUCATOR PREPARATION
PROGRAMS SO. THE COMMISSION HAS
PROPAGATED A RIGOROUS SET OF
TEACHER PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS
ALSO KNOWN AS TPP EIGHTIES. I'M
BUT CALIFORNIA'S STANDARDS FOR
THE TEACHING PROFESSION. THESE
EXPECTATIONS RANGE FROM THE
GENERAL ABILITY OF A TEACHER TO
ENGAGE IN SUPPORT ALL STUDENTS
IN LEARNING. ASSESSING STUDENT
LEARNING TIPS SUBJECT SPECIFIC
PEDAGOGY EXPECTATIONS. I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF THE
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE SOCIAL
SCIENCES POTENTIAL THAT ARE
RELATED TO PASS NEXT OUTING.
BEGINNING TEACHERS ASK QESTIONS
INSTRUCTURE ACADEMIC INSTRUCTION
TO HELP STUDENTS RECOGNIZE
IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BIAS AND
SUBJECTIVITY IMPOSTORA CLASS
ACTORS. THEY TEACH STUDENTS HOW
CULTURAL PERSPECTIVES INFORM
INFLUENCE UNDERSTANDINGS OF
HISTORY. THANK HELP STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND THE RANSOM CARE IT'S
FROM MULTIPLE PERSPECTIVES ARE
USING PRIMARY SOURCES
SIMULATIONS CASE STUDIES
CULTURAL ARTIFACTS WORKS OF
LITERATURE WHAT PROJECTS STUDENT
RESEARCH ACTIVITY. THEY CREATE
PUNISHMENT FIREMAN'S THAT
SUPPORT THE DISCUSSION OF
SENSITIVE ISSUES FOR EXAMPLE
SOCIAL CULTURAL RELIGIOUS RACE
GENDER ISSUES AND ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS TO REFLECT ON AND SHARE
THEIR INSIGHTS AND VALUES. THEY
WORK TO UNDERSTAND BATES
CRITICALLY ANALYZESOCIAL
SCIENCE ISSUES DATA RESEARCH
CONCLUSIONS FROM MULTIPLE
PERSPECTIVES. EXISTENCE STATUTE
THE COMMISSION BELIEVES THAT
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS WITH A
SOCIAL SCIENCES AUTHORIZATION
ARE SUFFICIENTLY PREPARED TO
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES THAT THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL. THAT'S
DIRECTORS SCHOOL AND I HOPEFULLY
KILEY. TEACHING EXPECTATIONS OF
OUR CREDENTIALED TEACHERS ON THE
STANDARDS FOR THE SOCIAL
SCIENCES AUTHORIZATION. RISEN UP
TO ENCOMPASS THE PRESS I THINK
STATE'S CURRICULUM. THE
COMMITTEE KNOWS ETHNIC STUDIES
IN CALIFORNIA IS CENTERED UP A
LOCAL LEVELS. WITHIN THE
REGIONAL DISTRICTS MAKING THEIR
OWN DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT THEIR
ETHNIC STUDIES PROGRAM LOOK
FUNNY. THE SOCIAL SCIENCE
AUTHORIZATION IS AN IDEAL BUT
THE SITUATION AS IT PREPARES
TEACHERS TO TAKE UP NEW
CURRICULA IN SOCIAL SCIENCES
TEACH. THAT'S THE LEGISLATURE
DISCUSSES HOW TO BEST PREPARE
CALIFORNIA FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB ONE A ONE.
EXPECT QUESTIONS MAY BE RAISED
ABOUT PROVIDING FOR A SPECIFIC
FINANCIAL FOR ETHNIC STUDIES
TEACHERS. THE COMMISSION CANNOT
BEGIN ANY SUCH WORK WITHOUT
EXPRESS STATUTORY AUTHORITY FROM
THE STATE INCLUDING RESOURCES WE
WOULD NEED TO DO SUCH WORK.
WHICH IT IS CURRENTLY. THE
DOCTOR KNEW EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR CREDENTIALS AS WELL AS
ADMINISTERING NEW GRANTS. UNTIL
SEPT JOHNSON HAS BEEN GIVEN THE
COMMISSION SOMETIME TO SAY WHAT
IMPACT LIKE STUDIES POTENTIAL
MIGHT LOOK LIKE. ESPECIALLY
WITHOUT DISCUSSION WITH OUR
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS AND THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
TODAY THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS IMPORTANT TASK
WE ARE PREPARED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. GO TO
THE- THE DIETS FOR QUESTIONS.
ANY ANY QUESTIONS I'D I'D
CERTAINLY DO- THANK YOU CHOI. I
DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD BE THE BEST
PERSON TO ANSWER BUT THE MOST
LIKELY A DOCTOR MIGHT TO TORRES
COULD ANSWER REGARDING THE
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK- AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT- IF YOU CAN
SPECIFICALLY ANSWER. WHETHER
THIS IS A BE A- ONE SEMESTER
COURSE SO WANT ONE YEAR. AND ONE
IS- DUST DETERMINED THAT YOU MAY
HAVE- CLASSROOM HOURS AND THE
HOW MANY. ETHNIC STUDIES SO
WOULD BE- COVERED IN THAT
CURRICULUM. AND HOW THE TIME
WOULD BE LOCATED HOW IT WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO. OBVIOUSLY. SOMEONE
POSSIBLE THEORY MAY BE BASED
UPON- THE LONGER HISTORY WHAT
THE POPULATION- SUCH AS- NATIVE
INDIANS SO I HAVE A LONG HISTORY
IS TORY. BUT THAT THE A
POPULATION SO NOT MANY S. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RANK WILL
BE- FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR BLACK
HISTORY- HISPANIC HISTORY ETHNIC
STUDIES SO- A PREDOMINANT- NICK-
MINORITIES. AND THE ASIANS TO
MEET FOLLOW AND- HOW THE TIME
WOULD BE SLICE THE WHAT- AMANO
WITH TIME WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
EACH ETHNIC STUDIES TO. THEN THE
EDUCATORS SCHOOLS TO DEVELOPING
MORROW- MODERN CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORK AND THE CONTENT THEY
MAKE A SUGGESTION WHAT TO BE
INCLUDED. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
VICE CHAIR CHOI FOR THE
QUESTIONS- SO THE- THE FIRST
QUESTION WAS HOW LONG- IS THE
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
REQUIREMENT- WITH RESPECT TO AB
ONE ON ONE AND THAT ANSWER IS-
ONE MASTER IS PARDONED. HOWEVER
IN L. EA CAN EXPAND THAT TO AS
LONG AS THE FULL A FULL SCHOOL
YEAR- AS FAR AS THE QUESTION OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES- AND AS
YOU ADVOCATED BY THE EXAMPLE OF
SPLITTING UP THE PRO FOR. CHECK
FRANK REPRESENTATION OF IS OF
THE STUDENT BODY POPULATION
THAT'S ENTIRELY UP TO THE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT- TO MAKE THAT CHOICE-
THE MODEL CURRICULUM WAS
DESIGNED SUCH THAT THEY CAN PULL
OUT THE DIFFERENT PIECES THAT
ARE RELEVANT TO THE STUDENTS AND
THEIR- AND THEN AND THEN FROM
THERE AND UPON UPON WHOSE ARE
THE ELEMENTS FROM THE MODEL
CURRICULUM SO THAT IT IS
RELEVANT TO THE STUDENTS WERE
SITTING. I ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU OF DR TORTOISE I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS-
MAYBE FIRST OFF- DOCTOR TO
ORDERS- UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
STATE'S POPULATION MAY DIFFER
FROM ONE STATE TO THE AND GIVEN
THAT DISTRICTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WOULD HAVE FLEXIBILITY. TO BEST
ADAPT I THINK STUDIES CLASSES TO
THEIR OWN POPULATION THAT IS NOT
TO SAY. IF I UNDERSTAND AND I
HOPE THAT I AM CORRECT IN THIS
THAT IS NOT TO SAY THAT THE
DISTRICT WOULD HAVE- YOU KNOW.
PREROGATIVE TO SAY WELL YOU KNOW
THIS. X. GROUP WHATEVER THAT
GROUP MIGHT BE- DOESN'T EXIST OR
OR OR NOT IN BIG NUMBERS IN THIS
PART OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OR IN THIS PARTICULAR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AT IGNORE ANY OF THE
FOUR GROUPS THAT ARE THE BASIS
OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES OR WHAT WE
HAVE CALLED THE FOUNDATIONS ARE
THE PILLARS OF MY CORRECT IN
THAT ASSUMPTION. QUESTION TO
DOCTOR TOWARDS. THANK YOU- THAT
IS A VERY GOOD QUESTION- SO
LOOKING AT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
AB ONE OH ONE- IT ACTUALLY IS
NOT SPECIFIED IN THEIR THE
SPECIFIC ETHNICITIES WHICH NEED
TO BE REPRESENTED IN THE ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE IN FACT ONE OF
THE FOUR- ONE OF THE FOUR WAYS
TO BE ABLE TO SATISFY THE COURSE
REQUIREMENT. GIVES TEAMS THE
ETHNIC STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM
WHICH IS BASED ON THOSE FOR-
ETHNICITIES- THE OTHERS ARE.
TAKING SATISFIED WITH AN
EXISTING ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE-
AGAIN IT'S NOT WHICH THE STAFF
MISSED TO BE REPRESENTED AND
THAT- THE THIRD IS AN ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE TAUGHT AS PART OF
A COURSE THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED
AS MEDIATED G. REQUIREMENTS- AND
THEN THE FOURTH IS A LOCALLY
DEVELOPED ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
APPROVED BY THE GOVERNING BOARD
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT. FOR THE
GOVERNING BODY OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOL NOW CURRICULUM ITSELF
ENCOURAGES SCHOOLS TO INCLUDE
DESCRIPTIONS ON. THAT MAKE YOUR
ATTENTION BECAUSE HE'S OF
STUDENTS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND FOUR MAIN
GROUPS- THAT WAY CHIR CHOI HAD
JUST- THERE ARE SIX OF THE
ETHNIC SAID MODEL. THANK INTO-
OTHER- ANOTHER DRIVER
POPULATIONS BEYOND THOSE FOUR
YEAH I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT THE
POINT I'M TRYING TO MAKE. AND I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT IS
THAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED AFTER
LONG DISCUSSION MANY YEARS- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT THAT WHAT ETHNIC
STUDIES IS THE STUDY. OF
HISTORICAL GROUPS THAT HAVE
POPULATED THE UNITED STATES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND I
UNDERSTOOD THAT IF IT WILL
DISTRICT DECIDED TO OFFER A
CLASS IN STATE NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDIES OR ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES. A STANDALONE CLASS THAT
CLASS WOULD- FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENTS BUT I'M TRYING TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT I DO NOT
THINK. THAT WE SHOULD LOOK AT IT
AS- A GIVEN THE FLEXIBILITY OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO SAY WELL
THIS GROUP OR THAT GROUP
ESPECIALLY ONE OF THOSE FOR A
GROUP. AT THE- MEDIA. HE
PRESENTED THAT THE JUST THE
POINT I WANTED TO MAKE- I HAVE A
QUESTION TO- I THINK. OF MR
DWYER FROM DIRECTOR OF
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES. DID I. I
I'VE HEARD YOU SAY THE NUMBER OF
SOCIAL STUDIES TEACHERS THAT THE CREDENTIAL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WOOD BURKE. YOU'RE
NOT IMPLYING THAT ALL THOSE
SOCIAL STUDIES. TEACHERS HAVE
THE KNOWLEDGE OR CAPABILITY OF
TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES. IS THAT
CORRECT. SO CRYSTALS THAT I
BELIEVE ALMOST FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND EIGHT YOU KNOW IT'S
REALLY KIND OF DIFFICULT TO HEAR
. I'M HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING
. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW BETTER.
OKAY I'M DIRECTORS WHO WILL
TESTIFY THAT IT'S ALMOST FORTY
SEVEN THOUSAND TEACHERS WHO HOLD
THE- SOCIAL STUDIES SINGLE
SUBJECT OUR CREDENTIALS. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE IT IS SUCH
A BROAD BASED CREDENTIAL THAT-
THE TEACHERS ARE PREPARED TO.
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES HOWEVER
BECAUSE EACH DISTRICT OR EACH
CHARTER SCHOOL WILL BE-
DEVELOPING THEIR OWN CURRICULUM
THERE IS LIKELY ADDITIONAL
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THAT
WILL BE NEEDED FOR TEACHERS. IN
MANY OR MOST DISTRICTS. SO IF A
TEACHER WHO TEACHES A PHYSICS
AND A HIGH SCHOOL- HAS A SCIENCE
CREDENTIAL IS THAT CORRECT. YEAH
RIGHT I HAVE TAUGHT IN HIGH
SCHOOL SO IT IF I'M A PHYSICS
TEACHER AT MY HIGH SCHOOL AND I
HAVE A SCIENCE CREDENTIAL. DOES
THAT MAKE ME- QUALIFIED. TO
TEACH CHEMISTRY AT THE SAME HIGH
SCHOOL AND MAYBE THE CREDENTIAL
IS. MAYBE THE SCIENCE CREDENZA.
MAKES ME QUALIFIED BUT IF I AM
THE PRINCIPLE OF THAT HIGH
SCHOOL DO I NECESSARILY WANT. A
PHYSICS TEACHER TO TEACH BIOLOGY
IF THEY'RE QUALIFIED YES BUT IF
THEY HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF
BIOLOGY- WHAT I WANT. THE
PHYSICS TEACHER TEACHING THAT
CLASS. OR IF I TEACH CALCULUS.
AT I'M A MATH TEACHER AND I'M
TEACHING CALCULUS DOES THAT MAKE
ME QUALIFIED TO TEACH CHEMISTRY
. LITTLE UNDER ASK MY COLLEAGUE
AARON TO TALK MORE ABOUT- WHAT
TEACHERS ARE ALLOWED TO TEACH-
BECAUSE THAT'S FOR HER DIVISION
YOU CANNOT I I'M- I'M GONNA
KINDA. I RESPECTFULLY ANSWER MY
OWN QUESTION AND THAT IS I DON'T
BELIEVE THE ASSUMPTION IF IT IS
AN ASSUMPTION THAT- THE
COMMISSION ON CREDENTIALING IS
MAKING AYE AYE I DO NOT ACCEPT
THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE WHATEVER
NUMBER OF SOCIAL STUDIES
TEACHERS THAT WHOLE CREDENTIALS
IN SOCIAL STUDIES ARE QUALIFIED
TO TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES AND I
THINK AS MY COLLEAGUE HERE MR
SANTIAGO WHO HAD TO LEAVE
EARLIER SAID THE PART OF WHAT
THE REASON FOR THIS HEARING. IS
THAT THAT IS NOT THE CASE THAT
IF WE WERE TO LEAVE THE TEACHING
OF ETHNIC STUDIES UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE I WAS IN THE CLASSROOM
AND IN A HIGH SCHOOL FOR MANY
MANY YEARS TO THE TEACHER. ALL
WHO HAVE BEEN TEACHING SOCIAL
STUDIES- HISTORICALLY. ETHNIC
STUDIES WILL FAIL. BECAUSE THOSE
TEACHERS ARE NOT QUALIFIED DO
NOT HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE SOME OF
THEM. ACTUALLY DENY SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED I REMEMBER
TEACHING ABOUT THE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT- WALKOUTS OF EAST LA
BY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND ONE
OF MY STUDENTS GOING TO HER US
HISTORY. TEACHER AND HER US
HISTORY TEACHER TELLING HER
EITHER DIDN'T HAPPEN OR WAS NOT
IMPORTANT SO- I REJECT THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE WHATEVER
FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND TEACHERS
THAT HOLD SOCIAL STUDIES
CREDENTIAL THAT THEY ARE IN ANY
WAY- QUALIFIED TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES SO I BELIEVE THAT THAT
THAT- AND ANOTHER QUESTION
PERHAPS TO DR TORTOISE DR
TORTOISE ULTIMATELY. WHO IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO SEE THAT WE
HAVE QUALIFIED TEACHERS TO TEACH
ETHICS. DOT PRESS. SO THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE QUALIFIED TEACHERS-
FALLS ON THE WILLIAMS ACT AND-
THE COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
DO YOU MONITOR- WITH RESPECT TO
WILLIAMS. WITH TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AS WELL AS
TEXTBOOKS SUFFICIENCY. AND THEN
MAYBE MY LAST QUESTION- ENGLISH
TEACHERS RIGHT A TEACHERS OF A
LANGUAGE ARTS. ARE THEY- THAT
WOULD SOME OF THEM ALSO BE ABLE
TO TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES. I DON'T
KNOW WHO WANTS TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. OKAY INTO THEM
QUESTION- NO THEY WOULD NOT BE
AUTHORIZED TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES BECAUSE- THE ENGLISH
AUTHORIZATION DOES NOT HAVE THT
CONTENT AREAS SUBSUMED WITHIN
THAT THE BROAD STATUTORY SUBJECT
OF ENGLISH. BUT IF THE DISTRICT
TAUGHT A CLASS LIKE. LATINO
LITERATURE OR AFRICAN AMERICAN
LITERATURE IN IN THAT IN THAT
CASE THE TEACHER WOULD BE IS
THAT CORRECT. IF A SCHOOL
DELIBERATELY INCITED TO TEACH A
CLASS WHICH I BELIEVE THERE ARE
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE A CLASS
LIKE. NATIVE AMERICAN LITERATURE
OR AFRICAN AMERICAN LITERATURE
ASIAN AMERICAN LITERATURE LATINO
LITERATURE WOULDN'T THE TEACHER
WHO HOLDS AN ENGLISH. CREDENTIAL
THEN BE QUALIFIED TO TEACH SUCH
CLASS. THE COULD BE IT DEPENDS
ON HOW THAT CLASS WITH COLLUDED-
FOR THE CALCUTTA STATE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT AND THAT. STATE
COURTS COULD THAT IT WAS
ASSIGNED SO THEY COULD BE OKAY.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
WEBER
YOUR COMMENTS I DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT SOMEONE WHO WITH TO JUST
HAVE THE BASIC SOCIAL SCIENCE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL- WITHOUT
HAVING ANY FURTHER TRAINING
SPECIFICALLY TO ETHNIC STUDIES
HAVE TO TEACH AT THE NEXT.
SHOULD BE ON THE ONES TEACHING
OUR KIDS ETHNIC STUDIES I AM I
AM NEWER TO THE LEGISLATIVE FIVE
I'M DISAPPOINTED THAT EACH
SCHOOL DISTRICT IT'S NOT READY
TO CONNECT CRAFTED ON- ETHNIC
STUDIES- CURRICULUM I THINK WE
HAVE STANDARDIZED SCIENCE WHEN
WE HAVE ENTERED AYE CORRECT WE
HAVE STANDARDIZED AMERICAN
HISTORY CURRICULUM IN SEOUL-
ALLOWING YOU KNOW THE INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO- DO THIS
WITH ETHNICS DAY IT IS VERY
DISAPPOINTING HOWEVER IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT LIKE I SAID
EARLIER WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING IT RIGHT. AND
IT STARTS WITH MAKING SURE THAT
THE TEACHERS WHO ARE TEACHING IT
REALLY UNDERSTAND AND KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE TEACHING AND HOW TO TEACH IT
THANK YOU. THANK THANK THANK
YOU- WHEN WE DELVE INTO A LITTLE
MORE SPECIFICS- I WOULD LIKE TO
ORDER SO EMPHASIZE THAT
SOMETIMES SO. ASIAN SLASH OF
PACIFIC ISLANDERS I'LL ROUTE
THIS ONE. HOWEVER THIS BUT THE
KILLER ETHNIC GROUP IS- TO MY
VIEW MOST OF DIVERSE IF WE
CATEGORIZED TO SELECT THAT
LATINO OR HISPANIC. I'LL JUST
SAY IT HAS A MORE COMMONALITY.
SPEAKING SPANISH AND OTHER
SIMILAR CULTURAL BACKGROUND AND
THE BLACK ETHNIC STUDIES SO. IT
IS A VERY SPECIAL ONE GROUP. BUT
THE AS YOU THINK ABOUT THE ASIA
ASIA IS. HOW DOES A VERY UNIQUE-
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IT IS A NOT
ONE RATIO WE MAY LOOK OUR ALLY
MANY SAY YOU ALL LOOK ALIKE I
CANNOT TELL YOU WHAT HOW AND IN
FACT THEY CANNOT TELL IT WHEN
THE I COME FROM CHINESE CHINESE
BACKGROUND OF KOREAN THAT BROWN
JAPANESE BACKGROUND IT EVEN SO I
CAN TELL A LITTLE BIT IN ALL OF
MY LIFE IS ON TIME SO- HOWEVER-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO'S NOT HERE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOLE- ORDER
ORDER GET MAD AT ME. IF WE LUMP
SUM CHINESE CULTURE INTO KOREAN
ETHNIC BACKGROUND. YEAH WHAT.
JAPANESE TO KOREAN CULTURE EVEN
THOUGH WE LOOK ALIKE. AND WE
SHARE A VERY THAT NAZARIAN
RELATIONSHIP JAPAN OCCUPIED
KOREA FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS TO C.
LEVEL INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONSHIPS NOT NOT SO GOOD
AND THE VERY UNIQUELY DIFFERENT
- MANY TIMES OF CHINESE
GOVERNMENT THEY EVEN TRIED TO
CLAIM OUR CURRENT CULTURE IN SA
FOR CHINESE SELEKA I- CELEBRATED
INTRODUCED A RESOLUTION TEAM TO
DAY LAST YEAR. CHINESE ARE
CLAIMING KIM SHE'S SO CHINESE
WOMAN. IN ALL THINGS LIKE THAT
EVEN KOREAN TRADITIONAL CLOSE'S
CHINESE CLOTHES AND THE KOREAN
PEOPLE GET SO MAD. THEY MAY
CLAIM BTS AS THE LIGHT LIKE A
CHINESE SO OF POPULAR CULTURE
HOST ON THE I DON'T KNOW. SO THE
KOREAN AMERICANS HAVE A VERY
POSSESSIVE- A- CHARACTER- THAT
THE WEEK CONTRIBUTED. I DON'T
KNOW IN THIS ROOM HOW MANY
pSEVEN E. DR SAM IN THE- YOU MAY
KNOWN. NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT THAT
HE WAS A MEDICAL DOCTOR HE HE
COULD NOT. PRACTICE- EVEN YOU
MEAN CORTISOL I UNDERSTAND HE
PRACTICES HIS DIVING INTO THE
SAND. AND HE WAS A- TWO TIME
OLYMPIC GOLD MEDALIST A AS A-
KOREAN AMERICAN HE WON THE TITLE
FOR AMERICAN AWFUL PRIA HE
HAPPENED TO. COME FROM KOREA SO
IF- JAPANESE UP NEXT TO IT IS-
INTRODUCES IT YOU KNOW THAT THE
- ASSEMBLY LEAVE. ASIAN AND ALL-
CULTURE- CONTRIBUTED- TO
AMERICAN IN ALL CULTURAL OR
HISTORY OF WHY CHEAP MUCH IN ALL
. THEY WERE SAID DOESN'T WRONG
NO HE WAS NOT UPPER EAST SIDE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THE SO
ANYWAY AS YOU CAN HEAR WITH THE
THREE DIFFERENT BUT THAT THERE
ARE SOME VIETNAMESE INTEL-
NATION ERA. EVEN EVEN SOMETIMES
UP INDIA IS A CLASSIFIED AS UP
THE SHOT PACIFIC ISLANDERS A
HAWAII AND SO HORRIBLY DIFFERENT
GROUP OF ASIANS ARE CLASSIFIED
AS A ONE LUMP SUM GROUP. SO IN
THIS- NEXT- CURRICULUM FRAME. AT
THE SLICING THAT TIME- TO L.
OKAY DEATH ASIA A ONE LUMP SUM
GROUP IT'S NOT GONNA WORK. THERE
HAS TO BE SPECIFIC GROUP LIKE I
HAD MENTIONED. AS A FROM A
PERSON WHO KNOWS TO A
DISTINCTIVE DIFFERENCES SO I'M
JUSTICE STAYING THERE FOR YOUR
FUTURE REFERENCE. THANK YOU DR
CHOI ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BUT MAYBE TO CLOSE THIS
PANEL OUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT I'M
REALLY. DISAPPOINTED FROM WHAT
I'M HEARING IN IN THIS PANEL. WE
HAVE A LAW THAT WE HAVE PASSED
IN THE LEGISLATURE. THAT
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY THE YEAR TWENTY
NINE THIRTY WILL HAVE TO TAKE IT
ETHNIC STUDIES REQUIREMENT BUT I
HAVE HEARD NOTHING IN THE
PRESENTATION. THIS AFTERNOON
THAT THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
LICENSING ISN'T ANYWAY ACTUALLY
DOING ANYTHING TO PREPARE FOR
THAT. TO THINK THAT THE TEACHERS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE QUALIFIED TO
TEACH ANY OF THESE CLASSES IS A
MISTAKE. AND AS I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE. MR SANTIAGO SAY IT
WOULD BE A TRAGIC MISTAKE
BECAUSE IT WOULD ONLY DOOMED TO
FAILURE. ETHNIC STUDIES WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO OTHER PANELS
AND I THINK AND I WOULD TELL THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO THE ACADEMICS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE HERE TO THE FOLKS THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN UC
AND CSU TO THE FOLKS FROM
DEPARTMENT OF AT STUDIES. IN UC
CSU. AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
TO HEAR FROM THEM WHAT THEIR IN
THEIR PROFESSIONAL OPINION. IS
REQUIRED OF THE TEACHER. IN A
HIGH SCHOOL TO BE COMPETENT TO
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES WITH THAT I
THANK THE PANELISTS FOR THEIR
TIME AND FOR BEING HERE AND I AM
GOING TO BRING UP THE NEXT PANEL
. DR ERNEST BLACK CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY DIRECTOR FOR
CAL STATE TEACH. KLAUDIA
MARTINEZ UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EDUCATOR
PROGRAMS AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. AND DR JIRO HILL
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES DEAN OF THE SCHOOL
OF EDUCATION. AT PACIFIC SPOKES
COLLEGE AND SO- DOCTOR HILL I
THINK YOU THE ONLY ONE HERE IN
PERSON- AND I WILL START WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. AND
WE'LL START WITH DR ERNEST BLACK
IF HE'S READY TO PRESENT.
REMOTELY. DR BLACK ARE YOU THERE
. I AM PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. AND WELCOME. THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON TO EVERYONE I
APPRECIATE THIS CONVERSATION. SO
I AM EARNERS BLACK I AM ONE OF
THE DIRECTORS AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATOR PREPARATION A PUBLIC
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND THE SYSTEM
MY DIRECTOR FOR CAL STATE TEACH.
AN ONLINE MULTIPLE SUBJECT
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY HAS
A STRONG INTEREST IN DEVELOPING
EDUCATORS WHO WILL BE PREPARED
TO ENGAGE K. TWELVE STUDENTS AND
ETHNIC STUDIES. THROUGH A
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION LANDS.
CURRENTLY I AM THE CHAIR OF THE
CSU COLLEGE OF EDUCATION DEAN'S.
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
GROUP. THIS GROUP WAS FORMED TWO
YEARS AGO TO TAKE A CRITICAL
LOOK. AT THE EDUCATOR
PREPARATION PROGRAMS WITH IN THE
CSU AND DETERMINE HOW WE AT THE
SYSTEM COULD BE MORE INCLUSIVE
AND REFLECTIVE OF THE CITIZENS
OF CALIFORNIA. OUT OF THIS GROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MADE
TO ENCOURAGE ALL EDUCATOR
PREPARATION FACULTY. TO
PARTICIPATE AND THE D. III
CERTIFICATE COURSE. OFFERED
THROUGH THE CSU CENTER FOR
TRANSFORMATIONAL. DECATUR
PREPARATION PROGRAMS ARE C. TE.
ANOTHER RECOMMENDATION WITH TO
REQUIRE ALL TEACHER PREPARATION
CANDIDATES TO TAKE AT LEAST ONE
COURSE AND ETHNIC STUDIES AND OR
OF COURSE WITH THE DVI LANDS
PRIOR TO ADMISSION TO OUR
EDUCATOR PREPARATION PROBABLY
DON'T DOCTOR HILL D. III IF YOU
WOULD JUST- SPELL THAT OUT
FORCE. ADVERSITY I EQUITY AND
INCLUSION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AS WE ARE ALL AWARE THEY ARE
SLIGHTLY OVER SIX MILLION T. K.
TWELVE STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OVER 70% OF THOSE
STUDENTS IDENTIFY AS AFRICAN
AMERICAN ASIAN OR HISPANIC LATIN
NEXT. CONVERSELY 63% OF OUR
TEACHERS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IDENTIFIES WHITE. AN
INCLUSION OF ETHNIC STUDIES
ALLOWS OUR TEACHERS TO GAIN THE
KNOWLEDGE TO EMBRACE AND
INVOLVED IN OUR CURRENT STUDENT
POPULATION. THIS PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR TEACHERS TO
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCES OF
CULTURE AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING CULTURE
AND TWO OF THE STUDENTS INTO THE
CLASSROOM. BACKER RESULT IN MORE
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT AND
ULTIMATELY HIGHER ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT. BY PREPARING
TEACHER CANDIDATES TO TEACH
ETHNIC STUDIES WE ARE PREPARING
OUR NEWEST TEACHERS TO TAKE
EXISTING AND DEVELOPING
CORRECTIVE I. AM BUILT A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING AND COMMUNICATION
ACROSS ETHNIC DIFFERENCES YES
WILL SHOP OUR COMMONALITIES BUT
ALSO EMBRACE. OUR DIFFERENCES.
PORTENTS FOR OUR TEACHERS IS TO
SHOW THAT AND BEFORE THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE OUR STUDENTS
LEYVA. IT BRINGS THE COMMUNITY
INTO THE CLASSROOM AND
EXEMPLIFIES OUR SHARED GOAL ARE
SHORT COMMUNITY GO WHICH IS OUR
STUDENTS. THE IMPORTANCE FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO THINK THEY FEEL SEEN
HEARD AND ENCOURAGED IN
CLASSROOMS. ALLOWS THEM TO
ACHIEVE ACADEMICALLY AND
SOCIALLY AND TO BECOME EQUITABLE
AND PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY. TO THIS END THE CSU HAS
CURRENTLY NAY IS CURRENTLY
MAKING GREAT STRIDES TO ENSURE
EDUCATOR CANDIDATES. HAVE A
STRONG FOUNDATION TO TEACH
ETHNIC STUDIES SOME OF THIS WORK
IS FOCUSED ON THE UNDERGRADUATE
CREDENTIAL LEVEL. FOR EXAMPLE
CSU FULLERTON IS DEVELOPING AN
UNDERGRADUATE MAJOR URBAN
LEARNING FOCUSED ON WHAT IS
CALLED JUST EQUITABLE AND
INCLUSIVE EDUCATION R. J. E. ID.
WHICH WAS RECENTLY APPROVED BY
THEIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS BUT
MAJOR HAVE SIX CLASSES ALL
FOCUSED ON SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
ANTI RACIST TEACHING. IN
ADDITION IT IS INTERDISCIPLINARY
WITH CLASSES FROM WOMEN AND
GENDER STUDIES AS WELL AS ETHNIC
STUDIES. THIS WILL BE FOR THE
FUTURE MULTIPLE SUBJECTS AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS AND
THE FIRST COHORT WILL BEGAN IN
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
ADDITIONALLY ADDITION OFF
ENTERING CREDENTIALS STUDENTS
EXHIBITION FLOOR TEN MONTHS
RIGHT A. J. D. I. E. STATEMENT.
ALONG WITH THEIR CREDENTIAL
APPLICATIONS. CSU LOS ANGELES
HAPPEN UNDERGRADUATE PROGRAM AND
URBAN LEARNING THAT HAS JUST
BEEN REVISED TO INCLUDE SPECIFIC
COURSEWORK AND ETHNIC STUDIES A
COP CANNOT USE ME CREDICO G. N.
ALSO INCLUDES REQUIRED ETHNIC
STUDIES EDUCATION COURSES.
UNIVERSITY'S COLLEGE OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. IN ADDITION TO THE
CHARTER COLLEGE OF EDUCATION AT
CSU LOS ANGELES THE COLLEGE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES AT CAL STATE LA.
IS AN INTEGRATED TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS
WHEN THE BE A PROGRAM FOR
CHICANO AND LATINO STUDIES. AND
THIS INTEGRATED PROGRAM ALLOWS
FOR STUDENTS TO EARN A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND TEACHING
CREDENTIAL AND FOUR YEARS. SAN
JOSE STATE HAS ESTABLISHED THE
ETHNIC STUDIES RESIDENCY PROGRAM
. THIS PROGRAM IS A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN SAN JOSE STATE LOTTERY
COLLEGE OF EDUCATION. AND HE'S
UNION HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN JOSE SO
CANDIDATES FOR THE SINGLE
SUBJECT SUCH HISTORY SOCIAL
SCIENCE PROVINCIAL ARE INVITED
TO APPLY AND SELECTIVELY
ADMITTED TO THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM BASED ON THEIR PRIOR
KNOWLEDGE OF AT EXPECTS- OR ONE
OF ITS SUBFIELDS EMPIRE
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH YOU.
ESPECIALLY AND ONE EIGHTH
ALIGNED WITH CORE PRINCIPLES OF
ETHNIC STUDIES SUCH AS ELEVATING
STUDENT AND COMMUNITY VOICES
ENGAGING AND CURRENT ISSUES OF
SOCIAL INEQUITY AND WITH YOU.
CSU LONG BEACH IS ALSO WORKING
WITH ITS ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENTS TO CREATE FORCES FOR
CREDENTIAL STUDENTS. WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO CREATE WOW IS THAT
WHILE IT IS IMPORTANT TO CREATE
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE TEACHERS
ARE ENGAGED WITH THE- POLICE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ETHNIC
STUDIES. IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
DEVELOP SCHOOL LEADERS WITH THAT
SAME MINDSET TO BACK AND CSU
FULLERTON REQUIRES ALL AND THREE
MASTERS AND EDT STUDENTS. ARE
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE AND IT
JUST EQUITABLE AND INCLUSIVE
ORIENTATION WHICH IS A HALF DAY
EDUCATION ETHNIC STUDIES
WORKSHOP. AND INCLUDE A FOLLOW
UP EVENT ALL AND ALL FACULTY AND
STAFF IN THE COLLEGE OF ED.
HAPPENING CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE IN AN ON GOING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND A
VARIETY OF JT I AREAS. CSU LOS
ANGELES HAS A MASTERS COURSE AND
RESEARCH METHODS ETHNICS BADDIES
- FOR P. K. TWELVE. WEALTHIER TO
DOMINGUEZ HILL HILLS OFFERS A
MASTER'S COURSE IN ETHNIC
STUDIES. AN EDUCATION WHILE ALSO
DEVELOPING A NEW MINOR THAT WILL
BE THAT WILL CREATE A PATHWAY
FROM ETHNIC STUDIES WITH SINGLE
SUBJECT EDUCATION PROGRAM. SAN
JOSE STATE IS HOPEFUL THAT THEIR
NEWLY CREATED SPARTAN
ACCELERATED GRADUATE EDUCATION
PATHWAY. WELL ALLOW
UNDERGRADUATES TO MAJOR AND-
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES AND OUR
CHICANO STUDIES AND
SIMULTANEOUSLY START TAKING
THEIR COURSE WORK TOWARD THEIR
CREDENTIAL AND A MASTER FARTS
AND TEACHING AND THAT WILL HELP
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF TEACHER
CANDIDATES COMING INTO THE
COLLEGE OF ED WITH THE ETHNIC
STUDIES BACKGROUND. AND
SIMILARLY MARKET ON A
PARTNERSHIP WITH SAN JOSE SO THE
CITY COLLEGE ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENT AND WHICH THEY HAVE
ALREADY ARTICULATED. A
ASSOCIATES DEGREE ENTER THAT
PATHWAY. FINALLY REACHING TO THE
FUTURE SEVERAL INSTITUTIONS HAVE
CREATED A PATH TO DEVELOP FUTURE
TEACHERS. COME TO COLLEGE WITH
AN EQUITY LANDS. CSU FULLERTON
HAS DEVELOPED A PROGRAM CALLED
TITAN FUTURE TEACHERS. THIS
PROGRAM FOCUSES ON J. E. I. E.
THE PROGRAM IS FOR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS IN ALL MAJORS ACROSS
CAMPUS WHO HAVE EXPRESSED ANY
INTEREST IN BECOMING A TEACHER.
THERE THERE ARE CURRENTLY
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THIS GROUP CSU LOS
ANGELES HAS CREATED THE BALLOT
CAST BROKE URBAN TEACHER LEADER
ACADEMY. A PARTICIPATE THEY
ANTICIPATE THAT THE PARTICIPANTS
WILL BE INTERESTED IN PREPARING.
TO BE A TEACHER LEADER FOR THE
ETHNIC STUDIES REQUIREMENT. CSU
LONG BEACH IS DEVELOPING A LATIN
ACCENT TO FORGET FOR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS THROUGH
THEIR HISPANIC SERVING
INSTITUTION TEACHER PREP GRANT
AND WHAT SEVERAL OF THE
STUDENTS. WHO WILL PURSUE THE
DEATH CERTIFICATE ARE
CONSIDERING TEACHING. AS A
CAREER LIST THUS THE ISSUE
COMMUNITY OF COLLEGES OF
EDUCATION INSPIRE EACH OTHER TO
BECOME MORE PROFICIENT IN THIS
AREA. IN ADDITION TO RCS
COLLEGES OF EDUCATION P. E. I.
EACH DAY AND HAS AGREED TO BEGAN
REFUELING WHAT OUR COLLEGES HAVE
ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE AND THAT'S
THE ISSUE INSTITUTIONS TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT WITHIN OUR
OWN PROGRAMS. AND I THINK THAT
WAS- AMOUNT FOR BUT THAT IS WHAT
WE ARE DOING AT IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU DR BLACK NOW WE'LL
HEAR FROM CLAUDIA MARTINEZ
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EDUCATOR
PROGRAMS AT THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. MISS MARTINEZ
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. OKAY. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERMAN DEAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME AS YOU
MENTIONED AS CLAUDIA MARTINEZ
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATOR PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECT ON BOTH OF WHICH ARE
HOUSED IN THE GRADUATE INTO
GRADUATE EQUITY AFFAIRS
DEPARTMENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF HOW THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S RESPONDING TO
THE STATE'S GROWING NEED. TO
PREPARE K. TWELVE BEGINNING AND
CONTINUING EDUCATORS TO TEACH
COURSES IN THE FIELD OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. DO YOU SEE AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW HAS A LONG
TRADITION OF PRODUCING
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS AND THE WORK
OF EDUCATOR PREPARATION IN
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR
TEACHERS. IS ONE THAT ALIGNS
SQUARELY WITH THE UC'S MISSION
OF RESEARCH TEACHING AND
SERVICE. ARE EDUCATED PROGRAMS
RECRUIT PREPARE SUPPORT PRE
SERVICE AND PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATORS. AND SCHOOL SITE
LEADERS ARE COMMITTED TO THE
PRINCIPLES OF ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE EQUITY AND ARE
DEDICATED TO MEETING THE NEEDS
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS DIAPERS
STUDENTS- YOU SEE THAT. TEACHER
EDUCATOR. TEACHER EDUCATION
SPECIAL DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
ACROSS ALL NINE OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN INNOVATING
AND MODIFY IT MODIFYING THEIR
EDUCATOR.ON CURRICULUM AND
PROGRAMS TO RESPOND TO MULTIPLE
EMERGING STATE NEEDS INCLUDING
THE NEED TO PREPARE EDUCATORS TO
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES.
MANY OF ARE YOU SEE TEACHER AT
PROGRAMS. HAVE DEVELOPED NEW
ETHNIC STUDIES CONCENTRATIONS
AND- PATHWAYS FROM THE MULTIPLE
AND SINGLE SUBJECT TEACHER
CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
DEVELOPING CURRICULUM THAT I'M
BAD SPECIFIC COURSES IN ETHNIC
STUDIES FIELD PLACEMENTS WITH
EXPERIENCE K. TWELVE ETHNIC
STUDIES TEACHERS AND
COLLABORATIONS AND MENTORING
OPPORTUNITIES WITH UNIVERSITY
ETHNIC STUDIES FACULTY.
UTILITIES TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE HAS
ESTABLISHED AN ETHNIC STUDIES
PATHWAY- HAD ESTABLISHED ITH
OTHER STUDIES PATHWAY FOR THE
TEACHER CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND THIS WAS IN
RESPONSE TO THE LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT'S ADOPTION AT
THAT TIME OF AN ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT FOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION. THAT'S THEIR
ADMISSIONS PROCESS THEY DO A
REVIEW OF TRANSCRIPTS ADMIT
STUDENTS. IN THE CORPORATE WHO
ARE LOOKING. I'M LOOKING THE-
ACADEMIC PEPPER IN THE ETHICS OR
GENDER FEEL. THEY'RE JUST
AMENDED THEIR EIGHT COHORT OF
STUDENTS AND BY THE END OF THE
THIS ACADEMIC YEAR WILL HAVE
CREDENTIALS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE SECONDARY TEACHERS WITH IT
AT THAT THAT'S AN ETHNIC STUDIES
EMPHASIS. ON THESE ARE ALL
CANDIDATES HAVE BEEN PREPARED TO
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES THROUGH
SPECIALIZED COURSEWORK AND
STUDENT TEACHING PLACEMENTS.
UC'S TEACHER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
ARE PROVIDING LEADERSHIP IN THE
PREPARATION OF ETHNIC STUDIES
TEACHERS IN WAYS THAT GO BEYOND
IMPLEMENTED CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT. JUST THIS WEEK UCLA
IS LAUNCHING AN ETHNIC STUDIES
TEACHER EDUCATION COOPERATIVE
WHICH IS PRICED A TEACHER
EDUCATORS NOT ONLY FROM THE UC
BUT ALSO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES JUST SUPPORT
THE ABILITY OF TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS TO BUILD PATHWAYS TO
PREPARE. ETHNIC STUDIES TEACHERS
AND ALSO AT UCLA AT THEIR ETHNIC
STUDIES CENTERS AND SCHOOLS OF
EDUCATION AND UCLA EXTENSION ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO CREATE AN
ETHNIC STUDIES CERTIFICATE.
PROGRAM FOR PRACTICING TEACHERS
. ALL THE OF PRO. THAT NEEDS TO
ARE ENGAGED IN AND THE TEACHER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN ADDITION
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF COURSES
AND CURRICULUM- INCLUDED ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CAP PIPELINE AND
PATHWAY PROGRAMS FOR
UNDERGRADUATE PRINTED AND
POTENTIAL STUDENT CANDIDATES TO
PURSUE TEACHING IN ETHNIC
STUDIES. FOR EXAMPLE UC SANTA
BARBARA HAS THE EXCEED A PROGRAM
WHICH STANDS FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE INCLUSIVE TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH IS A CLEARLY
STRUCTURED PATHWAY FOR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS TO BECOME
CERTIFIED K. TWELVE ETHNIC
STUDIES TEACHERS. OTHER UC
CAMPUSES ARE ALSO ENGAGED IN
THIS WORK- AND YOU'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY LATER TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT UC RIVERSIDE'S MODEL
ETHNIC STUDIES PATH WITH TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM. INTERVIEW
RED WILL ADDRESS COMMITTEE
DURING THREE- SO YOU'LL THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF A DEEP DIVE INTO HOW
THEY STRUCTURE THEIR PROGRAM-
THE SEVEN ARENA WHICH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONTRIBUTING TO PREPARING
TEACHERS TO TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES
IS IN THE SUPPORT OF
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR TO
CONTINUING TEACHERS. I'M AND I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
BEING ADDRESSED IN THE EARLIER
ON IN THE EARLIER DISCUSSION.
THIS WORK IS BEING PRIMARILY
CONDUCTED THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
SUBJECT MATTER PROJECT THE
STATE'S INTEREST SEGMENTAL
NETWORK OF TEACHER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS ACROSS ALL
DISCIPLINES. I WITH RECENT
FUNDING FROM THE STATE THIS
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECT IS SPONSORING SEVERAL
ETHNIC STUDIES FOCUSED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS INSTITUTES AND SEMINARS
FOR TEACHERS AND REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ALL OF
WHICH ARE DEVELOPED IN
COLLABORATION WITH. INFORMED BY
THE MOST RECENT RESEARCH
CONDUCTED BY UNIVERSITY HISTORY
AND ETHNIC STUDIES SCHOLARS AND
EXPERTS. MOST NOTABLY THE
CALIFORNIA HISTORY SOCIAL
SCIENCE PROJECT ONE OF THE NOT
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECTS HAS BEEN DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF.
SPECIAL TO ME BECAUSE FOR. THIS
YEAR AMONG THE C. H. S. AS P.
OFFERING FIFTY FIVE PROGRAMS IN
PERSON AND ONLINE FOR EDUCATORS.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT. THE
FOLLOWING PROVIDE FOUNDATIONAL
ETHNIC STUDIES TRAINING FOR ALL
SECONDARY ETHNIC STUDIES
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS IN
PARTNER SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS
ASSIST LOCAL SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF LOOK WHAT HISTORY ETHNIC
STUDIES PROGRAMMING IN COURSES.
PROVIDING ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM PLANNING FOR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS TEACHERS- HELPING
SCHOOLS TO INTEGRATING ETHNIC
STUDIES INTO THEIR HISTORY
SOCIAL SCIENCE CURRICULUM AND
PROVIDING COUNTY SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WITH THAT. WORK
FOR ANY ETHNIC STUDIES AND THE
CHALLENGES OR DEMANDS FOR
BRINGING THEM TO THEIR DISTRICT-
AND ALTHOUGH THEY CALIFORNIA
HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE PROJECT
IS PRACTICE PROVIDING A GREAT
DEAL OF LEADERSHIP- IN THIS AREA
. MANY OF THE OTHER DISCIPLINES
IN THE SUBJECT MATTER PROJECT
NETWORK INCLUDING THE ARTS
PROJECT THE GLOBAL EDUCATION
PROJECT READING AND LITERATURE
PROJECT AND THE CALIFORNIA
WRITING PROJECT ALL. I'M DEEPLY
ENGAGED IN ND DEVELOPING SIX
STUDIES FOCUSED ON COURSES AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENTS-
SERVICES- AT MORE PROGRAMS ARE
BEING DEVELOPED FOR THE TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE ACADEMIC YEAR
AND BEYOND. I WANTED JUST TO
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS BY SAYING
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU WITH OUR K.
TWELVE AND HIGHER ED PARTNERS AS
WE CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND
REFINE. ONE OF PREPARATION
CONTENT AND STRATEGIES FOR
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS IN SERVICE
TO OUR DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION- AND I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I'M OF THE
FOR QUESTIONS- AFTER THE- IS
GROUP- CONCLUDED. THANK YOU MISS
MY TEAM. WE'LL GO NOW TO DR GERO
HILL FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. DEAN OF THE
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION AT PACIFIC
OAKS COLLEGE WELCOME TO HELP OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR. BOARD CHAIR
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK T. ON
BEHALF OF OUR A. I. C. C. U.
GROUP- I REALLY HAVE TO COMMEND
YOU FOR YOUR POLITICAL COURAGE
DURING AN ERROR WHERE. RHETORIC
KIND OF BLURS THE LINE BETWEEN
TRUTH AND ERROR SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- THAT WE ENGAGE- IN
THIS WORK- AGAIN I'M THE DEAN AT
PACIFIC OAKS COLLEGE- WE HAVE
ABOUT. EIGHTY INSTITUTIONS AND
A. I. C. C. U. FORTY OF THEM
OFFERED TEACHER EDUCATION AND
PREPARATION- I FEEL LIKE WE ARE
DEFINITELY PULLING ARE. DOING
OUR PART TO. REDUCE HE TEACHER
SHORTAGE BECAUSE WE PRODUCE.
PERCENT OF ALL NEW TEACHERS TO
THE PROFESSION- AGAIN A LOT OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE REALLY
GROUNDED IN SOCIAL JUSTICE
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION.
AND HOW WE TRY TO FRAME THAT
SOCIAL JUSTICE IS REALLY
SPEAKING UP FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE A VOICE. WE TALK ABOUT
DIVERSITY IS NOT DISCOUNTING
PEOPLE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE COUNT. NOT BASED ON THEIR
ETHNICITY BY DIVERSITY OF THEIR
EXPERIENCES WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY%
WE WANT TO. REFOCUS OUR LANDS
AND WIDENING OUR CIRCLE SO THAT
WE CAN HEAR YOU KNOW EVERYONE
BEING A PART OF THE DECISION
MAKING. PROCESS WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH OUR ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT IT. LOOKING AT IT
FROM A- OUTSIDE IN- I'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
LOCAL SCHOOL DID. NOT UNIFIED
HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
WORK ALREADY ON THEIR STUDENT
THINK TANKS WERE IN FACT THAT
INVITED STUDENTS TO COME TO MY
CAMPUS. TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES AROUND HOW'S IT
GOING SO FAR LET ME HEAR. THIS
IS NOT. IT THEN IN OUR TEACHER
SO WE SEE IT FROM THE OUTSIDE IN
IN ORDER FOR US TO DO THIS WORK
RIGHT AND WELL.
TRANSFORMATION CENTER AND OUR
CENTER FOR EDUCATOR DIVERSITY IS
TO REALLY ENGAGE THE WORK- FROM
A PERSPECTIVE REALLY INVOLVING
THE PARENTS AND THE COMMUNITY
RIGHT I THINK IT REALLY IS A
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY AND I
ALWAYS TELL MY CANDIDATES THAT
HISTORY GIVES US THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF RIGHTING THE
WRONGS OF THE PAST BUT WE HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL NOT TO ENGAGE IN
OPPRESSION OLYMPICS BECAUSE THAT
REALLY DOES FRACTURE SOME OF
THE- POSSIBILITIES THAT THIS
WORK IS GOING TO DO RIGHT LIKELY
. THAT MEANT OF THE PAST. I'M
TIME THANK. BE MORE THAT THE
TABLE FOR US TO REALLY STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- I REALLY DO
THINK THAT- WHAT. HERE IT IS
TRYING TO. FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
ASSESS THE WORK PRACTICE AND
REALLY INTRODUCE IT I DO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT WERE CO
CONSTRUCTING THIS KNOWLEDGE
BECAUSE IT IS NEW I DO AGREE
THAT WE HAVE TO READ. I'M IN HIS
. TEACHES DOESN'T NOT DISAPPOINT
TRAINING BUT I DON'T WANT TO
SEE- INNER P. PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. RIGHT I WANT THEM
TO HAVE SOME INTENTION AT THE
AROUND. THE BURKE SO THAT'S AS A
ICC YOU HAVE REALLY CREATED THAT
PERSPECTIVE WE LOOKED AT SOME OF
THE KEY CRITERIA- AS- THIS
EDUCATOR PROP. RIGHT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THE SUBJECT MATTER
COMPETENCE YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND CRITICAL HUMILITY THE
MOST IMPORTANT PART OF THIS WORK
IS TO GIVE PEOPLE THE BENEFIT OF
THEIR HUMANITY. I SEE YOU I HEAR
YOU I LOVE YOU I REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT LOVE AND JUSTICE
KISS EACH OTHER ON THE CHEEK.
RIGHT THAT'S WHERE WE GET OF
THIS VISIT MINE SAY SO WE TALK
ABOUT LOVE JOY AND GENIUS AND
PEACE IN THE CLASSROOM THAT'S
REALLY THE PARA SHIFT. THAT IS
COURSE THE OTHER THING THAT I
CAN REALLY ENVISION IS THAT YOUR
YOU KNOW THIS LEADERSHIP
REQUIRES ACTION AND AT SOME
POINT IT'S GOING TO MATRICULATED
DOWN I COULD SEE ETHNIC TAUGHT
IN EARLY TODAY TO. GET MY OWN-
EXPERIENCE I HAD A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO MARKETS
GHARBI DOWN PRINCE ON SLAUSON IN
THE LOS ANGELES AREA AND THE
FIRST THING WE DID WAS STAND UP
AND SAY I AM SOMEBODY AND WHAT
THAT DID WAS THAT OF AND WHO I
WAS AND I MEANT SOMETHING. ONLY
EVER TALKED ME OUT OF- OUTLETS
ARE PART COULD BE WRITING
REMINDS ME OF WORDS OF THIS PAIN
ED NOT I'M BEGIN. I MEAN BEEN
THERE JUST IT WORK OTHER THING
THAT I WILL SHARE WITH YOU WITH
OUR INSTANCE. IS THAT SELF
REFLECTION. THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART FOR TEACHER
PREPARATION. GOSH I HAVE TO
ADDRESS MY OWN BIASES IN THIS
WORK RIGHT I DO HAVE TO BE
REALLY SELF REFLECTIVE. FINALLY
REYES IS CALM. CREATING THAT
SPACE BECAUSE IT'S NOT ENOUGH
FOR US TO PREPARE EDUCATORS TO
HELP PEOPLE POINT OUT THEIR
PROBLEMS WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
GET THOSE STUDENTS THROUGH THOSE
PROBLEMS RIGHT THAT'S THE
TRANSFORMATIVE RESILIENCE RIGHT
I THINK IF WE DON'T HONOR
PEOPLE'S HUMANITY EMPATHY AND
COMPASSION I REALLY DO THINK
WE'RE NOT COUNTIES BECAUSE
THAT'S THE PRECURSORS TO
BUILDING THIS RESILIENCE THAT WE
NEED. IN OUR STATE N. THANK LAST
. I AM IS THAT REALLY HOPE
TOMORROW COULD BE BETTER BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT WE ARE CREATING
ANOTHER LINK IN THE CHAIN OF
PROGRESS AND I REALLY DO THANK
YOU AND I'M HOPING FOR A QUICK.
LANE I LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
PARDON IF THE PARK OF MY
COLLEAGUES- ON THIS PANEL. I
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS TO BEGIN THIS
PANEL THE FIRST ONE- IT GOES
BACK TO THE- PREVIOUS PANEL. AND
THAT IS HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND.
TO THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING- WHAT I HEARD. WAS
THAT BECAUSE- I LEGALLY OR BY
DEFINITION ETHNIC STUDY IS PART
OF SOCIAL STUDIES. THEREFORE
ALSO STUDIES TEACHERS. COULD BE
AT THE STUDIES TEACHER BY
DEFINITION YES BUT IN
PRACTICALITY AND FOR THE BENEFIT
OF STUDENTS HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT AND MY SECOND
QUESTION TO THE PANEL ANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL WHO LIKE TO
ANSWER WHICH MISSION ON TEACHER
CREEK LANE BE DOING NOW. TO
PREPARE FOR WHEN THE REQUIREMENT
THAT GETS IN PLACE AND ALL
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GONNA HAVE TAKING
AN ETHNIC STUDIES CLASS. RIGHT
THOSE ARE MY TWO AND ANY OF
ORDER OR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
BEGIN FIRST TO ANSWER THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS- MISS MIKE WOULD YOU.
LIKE THIS GUY YOU'RE ON THE
SCREEN. YEAH THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
ENOUGH WELL I THINK I WOULD-
FOCUS BACK ON WHAT I WAS-
SHARING WITH REGARD TO THE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THE-
RIGOROUS PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO TEACHERS IN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA SUBJECT
MATTER PROJECT AT LEAST IN TERMS
OF THE WORK THAT I- C. M. IN THE
IN. COURAGE MEANT THAT HE
RECEIVE FROM EMPEROR SHOULD
WITH. OTHER EDUCATION PARTNERS
IN THIS WORK TO- TO DIRECT-
TEACHERS IN SCHOOL OTHERS TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE AWARE OF THE
RESOURCES. THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEIR TEACHERS BECOME PROFICIENT
IN THE WAYS THAT- MY ARM MY
COLLEAGUES ANIL WHERE DOES THE
CRITICALLY AND- AS WE GO FORWARD
AND AT THE EXTENT YEAH STUDIES
WERE- IS THAT. ABOUT KNOW. ALL
OF THIS SO DISTRICTS THE WERE
WERE READY FOR CARE TO- JEFF
THOSE. SPANNED AND CREATE NEW
ONES IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THOSE
EDUCATION AGENCIES WITH OUR
OTHER HIGHER AT. COLLEAGUES AND
WE RECEIVED RESPONSIBLE FROM
THOSE FROM THE STATE TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES WE HAVE A VERY
LARGE NETWORK OF TEACHERS IN THE
STATE ALONG THE FORTY THOUSAND.
IS OUR WHICH IS THE- ON A
PROGRAM SPONSORED BY THE SYSTEM
. AND SO THERE'S A OF AN
ACTIVITY THAT'S THAT'S HAPPENING
- WITH REGARD TO SUPPORTING AND
PREPARED I THINK STUDIES
TEACHERS NOW AND- AND I THINK
THAT WE CAN WE CAN CONTINUE TO
DO MORE. WORK GROW. BOB ALSO. R.
E. TO WORK ON THAT WITH- WITH
ALL THE NECESSARY PARTNERS. YOUR
HILL. YES I AM AGAIN- OMMITTEE
CHAIR- I WOULD DEFINITELY ECHO
MY COLLEAGUE- WE'RE HERE TO
HELP- I COULD DEFINITELY MENTION
WE HAVE A PROGRAM I SUBMITTED
EARLIER ADVOCACY AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE BY DEGREE JOHNSON TRACED
TO THAT THE BEST. THAT ALSO- WE
REALLY DO. OUR YOU KNOW OUR
EXPERIENCES IMPACT COMMUNITY WE
OFFER UP A FREE CERTIFICATE IN
JOURNEYS AND JUSTICE PURSES- TO
OUR INSTITUTION AS WELL FORTY
TWO. ENGAGE IN A PER. IN OUR
WORK. I DO WE CAN BE INVEST SOME
OF THE CAR- THE FIRE AND HAVE.
THERE CLASROOM WELCOME TO LEARN
THOSE SKILLS AROUND YOU KNOW
GETTING THEIR PEDAGOGICAL
REPERTOIRE AROUND ETHNIC STUDIES
BECAUSE IT IS QUITE DIFFERENT
THAN OUR STANDARDS SO STUDY
CURRICULA BUT I THINK JUST
COMING TOGETHER- LOOK AT CALL
WAYS MEETING THE NEEDS THERE IT
. NOW WHERE WE WILL WANT TO GET
. IT'S THANKS FOR WE SOUGHT OUT
AS THE THAT REALLY BENEFIT
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN AND I THINK
IT REALLY DOES TAKE IN OVER
COLLABORATION TO PULL THIS OFF
BECAUSE THE NEEDS ARE GREAT SO
WEEKLY WANT TO WAY. OTHER THANKS
WE BET THE COMPACT FATIGUE I
DON'T LIKE TO THE BURNER BUT I
THINK THERE THEY'RE EAGER FOR
THIS WORK AS I'VE IS SEVERAL
CLASS CLOWNS AND IN. YOU CAN
WEIGH IN CONVERT. YOU KNOW STAY
TASK FORCE IN THINGS LIKE TO
REALLY COME UP WITH THIS EQUITY
. THERE REALLY LEAN INTO THE
ETHNIC STUDIES WORK. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. DOCTOR HILL DR BLACK
. I WILL CALL DOCTOR HILL ON
PREPARING OUR CURRENT TEACHERS
TO BE ABREAST OF ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THE DUTIES
NEEDED TO TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES
IN OUR CLASSROOMS. OUR TEACHERS
MISSION FOR OUR TEACHER CANNOT A
FUTURE TEACHER CANDIDATES OUR
GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
TEACHER CANDIDATES. ARE REQUIRED
BOB BAER CREDENTIALING HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TEACH WITH THE ETHNIC
STUDIES AND ARE WITHIN. THIRTY
AND TWENTY THE.
WORDS ONLY SOCIAL SCIENCE. THANK
YOU DR BLACK AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE AND I SAW ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES THIS LAST SUMMER
DEPARTMENTS OF EDUCATION
SHIFTING SHIFTING GIVEN THE
SEARCH DANCES IT BUT WE HAD
EXPERIENCE THE YEAR. SCHIFF GEN
OF. WHAT IT IS TO BE A TEACHER
AN EFFECTIVE TEACHER SO I FAVOR
THAT VERY MUCH- BUT IN WHAT
DIRECTION WOULD YOU RECOMMEND
THE THREE OF YOU THAT THE DO THE
COMMISSION UNCONSCIOUSLY MOVE.
AS SPECIFICALLY THE CLASSES OF
ETHNICSTUDIES AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL. SHOULD BE A CREDENTIAL
IN ETHNIC STUDIES SHOULD BE A
CONCENTRATION IN ETHNIC STUDIES
A SPECIALIZATION WITHIN WHAT
DIRECTION SHOULD WE LOOK TO THE
COMMISSION. IT ANGELES MOVE
BECAUSE I THINK NOT TO DO
ANYTHING IS TO THROW UP YOUR
HANDS AND THAT'S WHAT I'M SEEING
RIGHT NOW SO. IN WHAT DIRECTION
SHOULD WE LOOK INTO THE
COMMITTEE ON CREDENTIALING
MOVING. SO THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THE BEST TEACHERS. TEACHING THE
SPECIFIC CLASSES AT OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS THAT MEET THE GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS YOUR SUGGESTIONS.
DR BY BLACK YOU MAY BE. IF I HAD
TO SUGGEST I WOULD SAY THAT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES WHAT OUT KNOWLEDGE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES I WOULD SAY IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE BUT AT THE STATE- I
WOULD I. BE AN AGREEMENT. AT
THAT THE COURSE WORK SHOULD
INCLUDE IN ADDITION TO THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR CREDENTIALING-
BUT ALSO INCLUDE- OF COURSE AND
ETHNICS. SO IN. IT WOULD BE
CERTIFICATE HE WELL BUT THERE'S
NO. PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN
THE SUBJECT MATTER. DR HIM YEAH
I AGREE ALSO- THE OTHER THING I
THINK WE DON'T WANT IT TO BE IS
A SOMETHING WORSE TRANSACTION
SOMEONE JUST CHECK A BOX THIS
ISN'T EVENT. A SAYS THAT WILL
BOB OVERTIME- I AGREE I THINK IT
COULD BE- MAYBE AN ADDED
AUTHORIZATION TO PRUDENT WELL AS
YOU GO BACK IN. VOGUE AND
RETRAIN ITSELF. SOME OF THE BAD
THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN
CONFRONTING FIVE- SO THEY CAN TO
PROFESSIONAL- AS WE'RE AS WE'RE
BUILDING AND- THIS NEW THIS.
PLACE CB. THIS PRUDENTIAL- WITH
THE BUCKET OF COURSE IS ARE
COMBINATION OF PRACTICAL MAKES-
YOU KNOW ACTION THAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE COMMUNITY I MEAN THIS IS
REALLY WHERE I THINK YOU KNOW
POLICY AND ACTIVISM REALLY COMES
TOGETHER SO THERE'S SOME
CREATIVE THINGS WE COULD DO WITH
THE PEDAGOGY AND TRY. ON THIS
WORK TO. TEACHER I KNOW THAT
THEY'RE WILLING TO DO IT BUT WE
WANT TO GIVE THEM THE SPACE BUT
YOU KNOW ALSO THE RESOURCES TO
DO IT RIGHT NOW WELL SO THAT
THEY DON'T FEEL SOME OF THE-
PRESSURE I KNOW WE YOU KNOW THE
SAME- DOES. IT ALSO CREATE AND I
THINK THAT'S THIS- THAT WE HAVE
. I MISS MY- YES HI I THINK
WOULD- YOU KNOW AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES COME ON THE SCENE OF
THIS WORK INVOLVING AND IT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO EVOLVE OUR
OUR PROGRAM OR NOT WORKING FOR I
THINK IN OF FULL DENTURE WILL TO
BE OUT HERE ARE WE REALIZE THAT
IS GREAT IMPORTANT. YES I'M IN.
THANKS DAVE. YES IS JIM AS BIG A
BETTER AT THE WAY WE DO IN THE%
AT PROGRAMS- MANY OF THEM ARE
DESIGNING PROGRAM SIMILAR TO
WHAT AN AUTHOR. LIKE OR WHAT A
CERTIFICATE WOULD LOOK LIKE SO
WE'LL BE DOING THAT- RGARDLESS
AND IF THERE IS A CREDENTIAL
THAT IS ALFA WILL BE PART TO
ISSUE. SAN WORK ON WE WILL HAVE
PLACE FOR THEM- CHIU PER THERE
THIRTEEN CRAFT IN OUR- WITH
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. ANY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MR GABER.
YEAH I THINK YOU MISTER TURNER I
WANTED TO ASK A QUESTION OF
DOCTOR HELP- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAVE BEEN VERY- EACH OF THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT AT ALL. ZERO
SHOW- BY THE WAY YOU DESCRIBE
THIS IS. LOVE AND JOY AND
JUSTICE AND HUMANITY AND EMPATHY
COMPASSION AND I. MORE IMPORTANT
PEOPLE THAN HUMANITY AND EMPATHY
COMPASSION ONE OF THE REASONS
I'VE BEEN A SUPPORTER OF
TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES IS
BECAUSE I THINK IT HAS THE POWER
TO- JUST FOR. REVERSED BACK TO
CVS HEALTH. IF IT'S THERE BUTTO
OPEN THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
STUDENTS OF EVERY BACKGROUND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WHAT
IS YOUR ADVICE I THINK YOU ON
TRUSTED THAT SOME OTHER PREP IS-
FOR TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES THAT
ARE MAYBE A BIT MORE NEGATIVE
HOW. BASS TO GET. OR FORTY
HISTORY WITH OF ITS AND ALL OF
ITS CHALLENGES AND ALL OF ITS
PAIN WERE BEING HONEST ABOUT
THAT BUT WERE ULTIMATELY GET IT
READY AND COMPASSION. YOU KNOW.
WORK FOR QUESTION. A ROBAR
COMMITTEE MEMBER GABRIEL- I
THINK IT'S- YOU KNOW I THINK WE
HAVE TO ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
TEACHERS ARE HUMAN TOO I THINK
THE BEST WAY TO TEACH IT IS TO
MODEL FOR OUR ABILITY BUT ALSO
VALIDATION BY I'M SOMETIMES NOT
OKAY IT'S OKAY NOT BEING OKAY.
RIGHT SOMETIMES YOU'RE JUST THE
POSSIBILITY CARE OF LEARNING
BECAUSE YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE
ANSWER. THANK THERE ARE SOME
GREAT DEALS OUT THERE WHERE YOU
KNOW TEACHERS ARE GRAPPLING WITH
IT RIGHT I THINK WE CAN LEARN
FROM OTHER PLACES THAT HAD KIND
OF A YOU KNOW. A MORAL AWAKENING
SO TO SPEAK BUT REALLY IT'S
BEING IT OUT OF THAT PHONE
ABILITY BUT ALSO YOU KNOW. HOW
THEY CAN I CAN. I SEE YOU I
UNDERSTAND HOW TO BUILD THIS
ISN'T SOME CONTENT DOES. PARTS.
RIGHT WHEN YOU HEAR SO OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE TO PEOPLE IN
THE PAST BUT I THINK THE HOPEFUL
PART IS WE'RE- WE KEEP. MOVING
TOWARDS THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
I THINK TEACHERS UNDERSTAND THAT
IT REALLY ISN'T A CAREER IT'S A
CALLING LIKE I ALWAYS SAY THAT I
WOULD LOVED INTO THE LIFE THAT I
HAVE. FIRST DIDN'T ONLY BECAUSE
- I LIKE YOUR SHOP AT SIX THIRTY
LET'S GET YOUR HOMEWORK DONE SO
YOU CAN GET A SCHOLARSHIP AND
GET TO COLLEGE SO THEY WERE
MODELING THAT EMPATHY THAT
COMPASSION FOR ME AS A HUMAN FOR
AND THEN I WAS DIDN'T SECOND. I
THINK PIECES UP THE PEDAGOGY TO
TEACH CERTAIN THINGS THERE'S YOU
KNOW GREAT CALLER YES AND IN THE
TALKS ABOUT THE REALITY PEDAGOGY
ARE YOU NOT BELL TALKS ABOUT.
THE ARTS JUST GIVE IT UP BROWN'S
TOPICS CULTURALLY SUSTAINED FROM
GLORIA LADSON BILLINGS AND
ENTANGLE PAIRS THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO TO
REALLY INSTILL THOSE VALUES TO-
ARE EDUCATE BECAUSE IT REALLY IS
A COMMITMENT AND WE KNOW THAT
PREPARATION- IT'S A COLLEGE AS
YOU KNOW I'M STEP OR I DID TEACH
THAT THAT'S THAT COULD SELF
REFLECTION I HOPE I AND YOUR
QUEST I REALLY THE PAR IT. THE
STUFF LEARNING BECAUSE MY YOU TO
OUR- BEHAVING CAN. I MEAN YOU'LL
GO TO THE MOON SO TO SPEAK RIGHT
SO I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT. AND ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR. S. OKAY- NOT JUST-
MAKE A COMMENT- NOT NECESSARILY
DIRECT ANY PARTICULAR PERSON BUT
THE MAY BE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. OUR DEPARTMENT OF
WAS IF CATION- WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THE CREDENTIALING.
CREDENTIALED TO TEACH HER TO
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES SO- THERE
COULD BE SEVERAL AVENUES. BUT
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY WE MAY
HAVE- ORDERS CERTIFIED WALK
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS SET TO A
TEACHER ANY PARTICULAR TOPIC. OF
ALL ETHNIC STUDIES SUCH AS-
CONCENTRIC JOHN ON BLACK STUDIES
TO EXPAND NEXT THIRTY SO. OR AS
I MENTIONED NOT ASIAN STUDIES
BUT THE- COREY IN A STEADY SOLID
JAPANESE STUDIES SO WHICHEVER-
I'VE BEEN TEACHING ENGLISH OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WHICH
INCLUDING. NEW WESTERN. FOR THE
UC IRVINE CAMPUS SET FOR TIME-
BUT THE I DON'T THINK I WOULD BE
HIGH AT THE BY- HIGH SCHOOL.
WHICH BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A- HE
TOOK A DANGEROUS A SECONDARY
SCHOOL CREDENTIALS AND THAT THEY
ARE VERY STRICT ABOUT THAT. SO
HE- SOMETHING TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES SELF OR PARTICULAR
SECTORS PARTICULAR STUDY. IF
THEY GET THE CREDENTIALS IN THAT
TOPIC IN THE SUBJECT THIS TIME.
BUT THE IF. ENGLISH TEACHER AT A
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEN I AM
HAPPENED TO BE A KOREAN AMERICAN
AND THAT I KNOW WE ENCOURAGE AND
THE MARKET HISTORY. AND THE PAID
A LOT OF PAIN AND UPDATE BIT
OVERWHELMED READING I THINK I
CAN BE A GOOD- NEXT THIRTY SIX
IN KOREA. KERCHER US BUT IT
COULD BE A SECONDARY LEVEL
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM MAYBE. AND
THE THIRD WAY IT'D BE- SO IN
OTHER WORDS SO THE EXISTING
TEACHER CAN BE ENCOURAGED TO ADD
AN ADULT STYLE PROJECT. IN
ETHNIC STUDIES. AND ASSISTANT
TEACHERS ALREADY ITCHING THAT
THE CHECK CAN BE ALLOWED TO
TEACH. AND THIRTY E. R. IF AND
WHEN- NO CREDENTIAL TEACHER OR
TEACHER ON STAFF ALREADY
QUALIFIED TO TEACH THEN BASED
UPON. THE RESUME EVALUATION IF
THE PERSON HAS HAD THE FOR
EXAMPLE OR- OF KOREAN STUDIES
CENTERS AT THE UNIVERSITY
SELLECCA UC RIVERSIDE DR EDWARD
CHANG IS EXPOSED IN KOREAN THIS
IS HOWEVER I DON'T THINK HE'LL
BE ALLOWED TO TEACH AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL. BUT THE BASIC THEN TEXAS
BATTICALOA HERE TO TEACH ONE ONE
NEAR AT HIS HIGH SCHOOL. THE
BASED UPON HIS BED BUT THE
SUPERINTENDENT ORDERLY- PRINCE
SPORE CAN MAKE AN EXAMPLE FOR
AND A TEMPORARY- HIRING FOR THAT
YEAR NOT AS A PERMANENT TEACHER
BUT THE YEAR TO YEAR EVALUATING
UNTIL THAT THERE'S FIVE COMES
AROUND CONVENTIONS COMES AROUND
SO I THINK IN IN ME SUCH OF
FINDING. REALLY THAT TEACHERS. I
DON'T ETHNIC THE STUDY GROUP SO
I THINK A COMBI OF ALL OF THE IS
CELL- AVENUES AND OF. BECOME
FLEXIBLE I THINK THAT MAY HELP
THE SHORTAGE OF A QUALIFIED
TEACHERS. THANK YOU DR CHOI AND-
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT- I HAD DR CHANG-
SPEAKING AT AT RIVERSIDE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AS HE GAVE. BUT
A LOT OF THE CAN AND WITH THE
OTHER OF THE OF USE YOU RESIDE
ON BUT AT LEAST IT LOOKED LIKE.
BUT IT IS OBVIOUS THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
NOT WAITING ARE NOT WAITING FOR
THE CERTIFICATE FOR THE
CREDENTIAL TO COME. THE I HAVE
SEEN OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS- THOSE INSTITUTIONS TAKEN
THE INITIATIVE TAKING THE
LEADERSHIP- TO ESTABLISH
PROGRAMS- ACADEMIC PROGRAMS FOR
TEACHERS. AND I'M REMINDED AND I
THINK WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
BEFORE IT WE STARTED THE SESSION
A WHEN I CAME OUT AS A TEACHER
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN SEVENTIES-
SOON AFTER THE ALLOW DECISION.
WHEN BILINGUE IT. WOMEN IN. OF
UC RIVERSIDE A SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AS A AS A TEACHER.
WITH A CONCENTRATION IN
BILINGUAL BICULTURAL- TEACHING.
AND I WENT INTO A BILINGUAL
CLASSROOM OF FOURTH AND FIFTH
GRADE WHERE I TAUGHT SPANISH I
TAUGHT READING. IN SPANISH AND
ENGLISH I TAUGHT MATH IN SPANISH
AND READING. AND THAT WAS
BECAUSE I HAD THIS
CONCENTRATION- FROM UC RIVERSIDE
CERTIFICATE. THAT UC RIVERSIDE
DEVELOPED. FAST FORWARD SOME
THIRTY YEARS LATER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SEEM TO CATCH UP
BUT IT TOOK THIRTY YEARS.
BECAUSE THIRTY YEARS LATER I WAS
AT THE END OF MY TEACHING CAREER
. WHEN THE PROGRAMS AND THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENTED
FOR CREDENTIALING. IN CLAD IN B.
CLASS AND HERE I WAS NOW A
TEACHER HAD NOT TAUGHT FOR
THIRTY YEARS AND WAS. WIRED TO
TAKE CLASSES IN THE SAME THING
THAT I HAD TAKEN SOME THIRTY
YEARS EARLIER AS A STUDENT
TEACHER AT UC RIVERSIDE SO IF
THE FOLKS FROM THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING ARE LISTENING. I
HOPE THAT IT WON'T TAKE THIRTY
YEARS BECAUSE THE INSTITUTIONS
OF CALIFORNIA OF HIGHER LEARNING
ARE TAKING THE INITIATIVE AND
DOING WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING
BUT I HOPE THAT WE WILL SEE. NOT
THIRTY YEARS BEFORE. THE AND
OTHERS A CREDENTIAL OR A PROGRAM
OF PUT IN PLACE- FOR DEFINING
WHO SHOULD BE TEACHING AND WHAT
SHOULD BE NEEDED AND WHAT THE
QUALIFICATIONS AND THE
COMPETENCY. DO YOU. LEARN WHAT
ARE THE COMPETENCIES THAT
TEACHERS SHOULD HAVE TO TEACH
ETHNIC STUDIES. WITH THAT I
THANK THIS PANEL VERY MUCH AND-
THAT WILL BRING UP THE NEXT
PANEL. THANK YOU. SO WITH THIS
NOW WILL BE DR LOUIS RODRIGUEZ
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE
INTERIM DEAN OF THE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AT UC RIVERSIDE. DR
MARGARITA BET THAT ARBELA
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR OF EDUCATION. DR
TESTAMENT BOLOGNA CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE
PROFESSOR CHICANO CHICANA
STUDIES PROGRAM AT CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE. AND A MEMBER AND
LEADER OF THE CSU ETHNIC STUDIES
COUNCIL. SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
. WITH MY GOOD FRIEND THE DEAN
OF THE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION AT UC
RIVERSIDE DR LEWIN RODRIGUEZ
HOPEFULLY YOU'RE THERE DR
RODRIGUEZ YES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEDINA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WHAT IS LOUIS RODRIGUEZ
I AM THE INTERIM DEAN A
PROFESSOR IN THE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON ABOUT
THE ROLE THAT THE UC RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION PLAYED IN
PREPARE AT SPEECH. BYPASS OF AB
ONE FUND MAKING IT THE- OF.
REQUIREMENT. 292-920-2920
THIRTY. I LIKE TO GIVE A VERY.
WHO IN THE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION.
TRIED RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF HIGHLY SKILLED IN
COMMUNITY RATHERTHAN TEACHERS
CONTINUES TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
PART OF OUR OVERALL MISSION AT
THE UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL EDUCATE
AND TEACHER PROGRAM CIVIC. AS
THE ALL UNITS OF THE CAP INLAND
EMPIRE REGION IT IS VITAL THAT
WE PRODUCE TEACHERS WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO SERVING OUR REGION
. ETHNIC STUDIES TEACHER- TO
THAT MISSION FOR A LITTLE
BACKGROUND TWO YEARS BEFORE THE
PASSAGE OF AB ONE A ONE. UCR'S
OF IT CAME IN AT SIX THIRTY IS
AN OPPORTUNIST AS PART OF OUR
CURRENT TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM. THE IDEA WAS. OUR
REGULAR BIRD OF TEACHER
EDUCATION CANDIDATES AND UPON
MATRICULATION STUDENTS IN ANY
PROGRAM COULD APPLY TO BECOME
PART OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES
EMPHASIS. TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
ACADEMIC YEAR WE PILOTED I THINK
STUDIES EMPHASIS PROGRAM. ALL
TEACHER EDUCATION STUDENTS WERE
ELIGIBLE FROM ANY SUBJECT AREA
AND ACROSS MULTIPLE SUBJECT FOR
SUBJECTS STUDENTS. IN THIS
PRIVATE BEER TWENTY FIVE OUR
STUDENTS EXPRESSED INTEREST.
OVER THE NEXT YEARS. THIRTY ONCE
EXPRESSED INTEREST AT THE
EMPHASIS. STUDENTS AMERICAN
STUDIES EMPHASIS TAKE THREE
ADDITIONAL COURSES FOCUSED ON K.
TWELVE I THINK STUDIES. CRITICAL
PEDAGOGY PEDAGOGIES OF RACIAL
JUSTICE AND NEXT YEAR A
CLUSTERED SECTION WITHIN THE
PROGRAM CAPSTONE COURSE WHERE
STUDENTS WERE IN EFFECT STUDIES
PARKWAY WILL JOIN A COHORT OF
STUDENTS PURSUING THAT NEXT
TEMPERATURES. OF COURSE STUDENTS
AND THE STUDY'S EMPHASIS ALSO
RECEIVE ACCESS TO A SPEAKERS
RESERVE EXPERT TO FOCUS ON
ETHNIC STUDIES IN UNIVERSITIES
AND OR SCHOOL DO. WHAT UP TO SIX
CORES AND TWENTY AND OTHER
RELATED TOPICS WHICH ALL SERVICE
PROFESSION UP. FORCED DURING THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO ACADEMIC
YEAR WE CREATED THE ETHNIC
STUDIES PATHWAY. THIS APPROACH
WAS SLIGHTLY ENHANCED BY
PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH ALL OF
THE PROGRAMMATIC OPPONENTS I
MENTIONED ABOVE PLUS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ALONGSIDE A
DISTRICT COOPERATING TEACHER WHO
TEACHES WITH AN ETHNIC STUDIES
LANDS. EVEN OUR EFFORTS OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS WE HAVE HAD
FIFTY NINE YOU SEE OUR TEACHER
EDUCATION CANDIDATES TAKING THE
EMPHASIS OR PATH WE ROUTE. THIS
MEANS THAT FIFTY NINE FUTURE
TEACHERS WOULD HAVE BEEN EXPOSED
TO ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE WORK
CONTEXT PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE HISTORY
PEDAGOGY RESEARCH AND IMPACT
THAT ETHNIC STUDIES HAS ON
STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY INDICATED
TWELVE SYSTEM. SECOND COMPONENT
OF UCR'S WORK IS TO USE YOUR
EXTENSION. I A LONGTIME
ALONGSIDE SOME OF MY SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
COLLABORATING WITH YOU SEE OUR
EXTENSION TO CREATE A
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM FOR IN
SERVICE TEACHERS. ARE COLLEAGUES
IN UCR EXTENSION HAVE LED THE
WAY BY SERVING IN SERVICE
TEACHERS THROUGH ONLINE ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE WORK. THIS
PROGRAM IS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
ACROSS THE STATE AND IS
ACCESSIBLE TO IN SERVICE
TEACHERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION TO IN
SERVICE TEACHERS EXTENSION
PROGRAM CERTIFICATE ALSO SERVES
ADMINISTRATORS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. THIS CERTIFICATE WAS
LAUNCHED LATE IN THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND TO DATE
TWENTY SIX IN SERVICE TEACHERS
HAVE RECEIVED AN ETHNIC STUDIES
CERTIFICATE. THIS PROGRAM IS
EXCITING BECAUSE IT GREW OUT OF
A WORKING PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT USE YOUR
EXTENSION. USE YOUR MEDICATION.
I LIKE TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT A PATH WE- STRUCTURE IN
THE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION THAT
WE'VE CREATED. AS WE THINK ABOUT
DEVELOPING FUTURE EDUCATION
TEACHERS IT IS VITAL FUTURE
ETHNIC STUDIES TEACHERS IT IS
VITAL THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF DEVELOPING VARIOUS
PATHWAYS INTO THE TEACHING
WORKFORCE IN AREAS LIKE THE
INLAND EMPIRE FOR EXAMPLE THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
IDENTIFYING FUTURE TEACHERS
EARLY. DEVELOPING MECHANISMS TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS ENSURING THAT THEY
REMAIN BABY COMMITTEE. GEN UP.
FOR WHAT THESE REASONS UCR
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION HAS
DEVELOPED A PATHWAY PROGRAM THAT
IS POISED TO SERVE AS A VEHICLE
TO THE TOP IN THE REGION AMID.
OTHERS ARE THE REGION AND THIS
CALIFORNIA. THIS PROGRAM IS
CALLED THE FIERCE SCHOLARS
PROGRAM IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL
OF EDUCATION LAUNCHED THIS BEER
SCHOLARS PROGRAM IN ADMITTED ITS
FIRST COHORT OF TWELVE STUDENTS.
HERE STANDS FOR. AMP REGION
EDUCATORS THIS IS A GROW YOUR
OWN TYPE PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES A
MULTI YEAR COMMITMENT FROM THE
SKY UCR SCHOOL OF EDUCATION TO
STUDENTS IN THE EDUCATION MAJOR
STUDENTS WILL BECOME FIERCE.
WILL RECEIVE SCHOLARSHIP
SCHOLARSHIPS PROVIDE MENTORSHIP
CURRICULUM PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND ACCORDING
SPIRITS. YOUR SCHOLARS ARE
ADMITTED DURING THEIR JUNIOR
YEAR S. CURRENT YARN IT'S OR
INCOMING TRANSFER STUDENTS. YOUR
SCHOLARS RECEIVE SUPPORT FIRST
YEAR IN THEIR MASTER'S DEGREE
PROGRAM IN THE UCR SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AS WELL SO THIS IS A
THREE YEAR COMMITMENT. THE GOAL
IS FOR THE PLAYERS TO EARN A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN THE TEACHER
EDUCATION. TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAM. OR OTHER SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. SCHOLARS
MUST COMMIT TO SERVING THE
INLAND EMPIRE FOR FOUR YEARS FOR
FOUR YEARS UPON GRADUATE
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE. WE
BELIEVE THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
UPON THE WORK IT HAS ALREADY
BEEN HAPPENING IN THE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION TO DRIP PROGRAM HERE
AT U. C. R. AND SERVE AS A
VEHICLE TO AMPLIFY THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE AND THE F. WORK.
FUTURE THIS IS ONE TAP IN THE UC
SCHOOL OF. THAT IS INTENSE
BUILDING OPPORTUNITIES TO
RECRUIT. RETAIN AND DEVELOP THE
FUTURE WORKFORCE AND HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO SPECIFICALLY FUEL
THE ETHNIC STUDIES. TEACHER
WORKFORCE FOR THE REGION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN
CONCLUSION YOU SEE I WAS ABLE TO
GET A HEAD START. ON THE
PROGRAMMING REQUIRED TO DEVELOP
FUTURE ETHNIC STUDIES TEACHERS.
DEPENDING ON THE DIRECTION OF
POSSIBLE FUTURE REQUIREMENTS.
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS WE
BELIEVE WE HAVE A WE HAVE
CREATED A FOUNDATION TO MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WORK MUST
INVOLVE COLLABORATION AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LOCAL
DISTRICTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
BILLION OPERATE THESE WITHOUT TO
SEE CAMPUSES AND CALL ACROSS
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
DR RODRIGUEZ. AFTER MONEY I NEED
TO VENT THAT OBVIOUS. IF YOU
WHEN I BEGIN WELCOME THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR JOSE
MEDINA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I SHARED MY NAME IS
MIKE I THOUGHT ABOUT THAT A LOT
A PROFESSOR OF EDUCATION- AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AND I PLAY FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE LOOKING TO
RECEIVE SCHOOL CREDENTIALS AND-
RIGHT OFFICER WITH THE CAN BRING
IT BACK ASSOCIATION. AND I WANT
TO DOT. MILLER I MEMBER ME AS
DIAZ. AND AS A CHICANO CHICANA
STUDIES MADE- I WAS NOT INFORMED
AT ALL ABOUT MY HISTORY- WHERE I
CAME FROM OR OR HOW I WAS
GROUNDED IN THE COPY. OF AND THE
- IT WASN'T UNTIL MY FIRST
CHICANO CHICANA STUDIES CLASS
WITH DR I HAD A SOCIETY THAT
THAT- IT WAS AN OPENING OF
REVELATION- ALMOST A
METAMORPHOSIS OF HOW I SAW
MYSELF HOW I VIEW MYSELF AND IT
WAS. WHICH GOT ME. I MAY THE
VERY INTENSE TO SEE TO BE A
TEACHER IN ORDER TO REALLY OFFER
AN ALTERNATIVE TO WHAT I HAD
RECEIVED IN EDUCATION SO I FRAME
MY TALK TODAY A LITTLE BIT- IN
THAT CONTEXT ALSO IN THE CONTEXT
OF WHAT I'M ON GROUND WHAT THE
TEACHERS THAT- AND PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS THAT I'M WORKING WITH.
SO IN THAT SEVERAL MANY OF US
HAVE WITNESSED AN ORGANIZED THE
RIGHTEOUS SURGE IN HOLDING
DISTRICTS ACCOUNTABLE TO THEIR
STUDENTS AND IMPLEMENTING ETHNIC
STUDIES AS A HIGH SCHOOL
REQUIREMENTS. AT THE STATE LEVEL
THOSE SAME TO HAVE MANIFESTED
WITH AB ONE OH ONE. AND NOW
LEGISLATION EXISTS THAT
SOLIDIFIES THE RITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF ALL STUDENTS
TAKING ETHNIC STUDIES HOWEVER A
MAJOR QUESTION STILL EXISTS
WHICH IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO ANSWER IT SHOULD BE ALL
AFTERNOON. COOL TEACH AT THIRTY
. WHO WILL PREPARE PRE AND
INSERVICE TEACHERS TO TEACH
EXPERTISE AND HOW WILL THEY BE
PREPARED. AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
ETHNIC STUDIES PROGRAMS ARE THE
TEACHERS TO THIS POINT CHRISTINE
LEADER STATES AND I QUOTE I
THINK THESE TEACHERS MUST BE
ABLE TO RELATE WELL WITH THEIR
STUDENTS. BUT EVEN IF IN FACT
MAKE ABILITY. WHAT'S NEXT THAT
IS CONTENT AND PERSPECTIVE WELL
- BUT THIS IS NOT WHAT ALWAYS
HAPPENS. SOMETIMES THEY ARE
MEMBERS OF THE SAME ETHNIC
BACKGROUND OF MOST OF THEIR
STUDENTS CURRENTLY IN MOST
PLACES THE OPPOSITE OCCURS. ONE
NEED ONLY HAVE AS YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD. A SOCIAL SCIENCE
CREDENTIAL TO BE ABLE TO TEACH
ETHNIC STUDIES IN ORDER TO SEAL
THE SAME RESULT REPORTED IN
THEATERS RESEARCH NOTED ABOVE
FUTURE I THINK THE TEACHERS NEED
CRITICAL COULD TEACHING
CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS THAT IS
WORKING IN COLLABORATION WITH
STRONG UNDERGRADUATE ETHNIC
STUDIES. JEAN CAMMACK MINIMUM
WORKING PAN AFRICAN OR APPEAR
MAJORS AND IN SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND OR
DEVELOP CERTIFICATES ALSO IN
COLLABORATION. THIS SHOULD NOT
BE AN EITHER OR BECAUSE OF THE
IMPORTANCE FOR THESE TWO
ENTITIES TO WORK TOGETHER BASED
ON THE EXPERTISE OF CONTENT. TO
GO G. AND METHODOLOGY. AS JUST
EARLIER INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT
WAITING RIGHT WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD AND YOU'LL ALSO HEAR
FROM MY COLLEAGUE DR THAT IS
SOMEONE DANIEL. THE COMMISSION
CANNOT EITHER. AND I SAY THIS
WITH THE EXAMPLE THAT I'M ABOUT
TO SHARE RIGHT NOW IN THE
POSITION THAT I CURRENTLY HOLD
NOT ONLY IS THE PROFESSOR BUT
ALSO AS SERVING AS A LIAISON
BETWEEN ETHNIC STUDIES AND ARE
STILL SUBJECT CREDENTIAL AS AN
ADVISER. I TO REALLY COME TO IN
A PROFOUND WAY. AS I SHARE THAN
CURRENT ADVISING ETHNIC STUDENTS
AT SACRAMENTO STATE THAT WANT TO
BE HIGH SCHOOL TEACHERS AND
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES AND I JUST
WANT TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT ETHNIC STUDIES IS. THE PLAN
IN AND OF ITSELF. AND THERE ARE
DEFINITELY POINTS WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER AND CONTINUE TO ONE
PACK. BECAUSE THERE IS NO ETHNIC
STUDIES CREDENTIAL WHICH IS WHAT
I WOULD HIGHLY ENCOURAGE IN
ADDITION TO OTHER ALTERNATIVES
ARE UNDERGRADUATE ETHNIC STUDIES
MAJORS CURRENTLY THAT HAVE NOT
YET ENTERED PREVENTION PROGRAM
THE PRE SERVICE TEACHER BUT WILL
TO BE TEACHER. FROM MY- HI WILL
THE WORK. AS ALREADY MENTIONED
THAT CURRENTLY TEACH OR WANT TO
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES MUST HAVE A
SOCIAL SCIENCE CREDENTIAL BUT
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT THEY
HAVE ANY BACKGROUND IN THE
DISCIPLINE. SB STUDIES MAJORS
UNDERGRADUATES FOR THE MOST PART
WHY COULDN'T FIND IT WITH THE
FACT THAT THEIR MAJOR EVEN
THOUGH IT IS I THINK STUDIES
WILL STILL NOW ALLOW THEM WILL
NOT ALLOW THEM TO TEACH. ETHNIC
STUDIES. AND MAKE DECISION THE
ULTIMATELY FORCES THEM TO REDUCE
THEIR CONTENT AREA TO ANOTHER
AND OTHER AND LET ME EXPLAIN
WHAT I MEAN. THEY HAVE TO THEY
HAVE TO DECIDE. MY MANAGEMENT-
BUT THEN ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
TAKING ALL THE COURSES NECESSARY
OUTSIDE OF THEIR FIELD IN THIS
CONTEXT SOCIAL SCIENCE TO MEET
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCY IN
SOCIAL SCIENCE WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH ETHNIC STUDIES
FACULTY QUITE CLOSELY TO
DETERMINE WHICH ARE THOSE
APPROPRIATE COURSES VIA THE
PROPAGATION OF MEANS OF ETHNIC
STUDIES WE SAID SHE- ARE. VIA
THE SEAT AND THE MADE IT MAY
SUCH AS ENGLISH MATH TO NAME A
FEW CAN DEMONSTRATE SUBJECT
MATTER COMPENSATE JUST BE OTHER
MAJOR BUT THIRTY. NOT THIS IS
THE CASE FOR ETHNIC STUDIES AS
OF NOW IT HAS TO BE COMPLETED
THROUGH SOCIAL SCIENCE WHICH CAN
ADD TIME TO GRADUATION
ESPECIALLY IF NOT ADVISED EARLY
ENOUGH WHICH IS WHERE MY ROLE
COMES IN RIGHT NOW I'M NOT
TRYING TO GET THEM. EVEN BEFORE
THEY TRANSFER SACRAMENTO STATE
OR WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY FIRST
YEAR STUDENTS IN WHICH ETHNIC
STUDIES MAJORS WOULD THEN IF NOT
ADVISED EARLY ENOUGH WOULD HAVE
TO TAKE THE C. SETS. WHICH IS
SUBJECT MATTER DEMONSTRATE
SUBJECT MATTER WHICH CAN BE
COSTLY. AS WELL OF NO RELEVANCE
TO THEIR DISCIPLINE AS ETHNIC
STUDIES MAJORS. SO IF THEY
DETERMINE THAT IT WANTS A MAJOR
ANYTHING MAJOR REALIZES THAT
THEIR MAJOR DOESN'T COUNT. KATE
DO THEY THEN THAT'S WHAT I DO
SHARE JUST ONE ROUTE ANOTHER
ROUTE IS MAINTAINED A MAJOR BUT
DOUBLE MAJOR SOCIAL SITES. OR
DECIDE TO NO LONGER MAJOR
DNEVNIK STUDIES MAJOR IN SOCIAL
SCIENCE AND POSSIBLY MINOR IN
ETHNIC STUDIES- SOMETHING
IMPORTANT T NOTE. WHICH ARE DR
MANTAN YOU'LL SHARE A LOT MORE
ABOUT IS HOW POWERFUL IT IS WHEN
STUDENTS CAN WORK ON THE ETHNIC
STATUS MAJOR AND ALSO HAVE AN
EMPHASIS CONCENTRATION IN
EDUCATION FOR EXAMPLE STUDENTS
AT SACRAMENTO STATE WHO WANTS TO
BE BILINGUAL EDUCATION TEACHERS
OR TEACHING- BUT SETTINGS CAN
HAVE SUCH A CONCENTRATION WITH
COURSES FOR EXAMPLE THE ADOPTION
TO BILINGUAL ED POLICY PRINCIPLE
SIX BUT- S. NEXT. YEAR'S THAT
THE CONCERT. GOING IN. OUR
TEACHER AGE. A COLLABORATION
THAT FORGED BETWEEN TEACHING
CREDENTIALS AND ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENT MOREOVER AN
INTENTIONAL COLLABORATION OF
ADVISING BETWEEN THE TWO
DEPARTMENT PROGRAMS AS SUCH I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS A SHARED AS
THE LIAISON ADVISOR ESPECIALLY
FOR THE STUDENTS INTERESTED IN
TEACHING IS CRITICAL AND I HAVE
FOUND IT CRITICAL TO KEEP MY
COLLEAGUES IN ETHNIC STUDIES
APPRISED OF CHANGES LEGISLATION
EXCEPTION WHICH COULD IMPACT
TRAJECTORIES BUT DEFINITELY
CALLS FOR JOINT WORK. WHAT I DO
SURE RIGHT NOW IS ALL BEFORE
THEY EVEN ENTER THE
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM POINTS WE
HAVE TO CONSIDER. INCREASE
SERVICE ULTIMATELY FOR PRE
SERVICE CANDIDATES A STRONG
UNDERGRADUATE ETHNICS MID
THIRTIES MAJOR WITH THE
pIS CRITICAL. AND THEN THE ANSWER
FIFTY YEAR PROGRAM. ARE TEACHING
CREDENTIALS IN WHICH ALL
AFFINITY CONCENTRATIONS WOULD
MERGE VIA AND ALL YOUR METHODS
PEDAGOGY COURSES AND OTHER
COURSES. FEEL PLACEMENT IS
CRUCIAL. THE SCHOOL THE TEACHER
THEIR BACKGROUND AND HAVING
BACKGROUND IN ETHNIC STUDIES. IF
THERE'S CONSIDERATION OF
AUTHORIZATIONS OR INTRODUCTORY
SUBJECT MATTER AUTHORIZATIONS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO STILL REMEMBER
THAT IT'S STILL PUTS THE STUDENT
SERVICE TEACHER IN A POSITION OF
STILL HAVING TO HAVE A SOCIAL
SCIENCE COULD ENSURE. AND THEN
HAVE THE AUTHORIZATION TOP OF
THEIR CREDENTIALS SO AGAIN
PUTTING INTO EFFECT OF THE TIME. NOW AT THE SAME TIME LET'S SAY
AN ETHNIC STUDIES CREDENTIAL
COMES TO FRUITION AND YOU HAVE
STUDENTS THEIR SOCIAL SCIENCE
TEACHER CREDENTIAL CANNONS OR
OTHER CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
THEN THURSDAY SHE COULD BE
VIABLE AND VERY POWERFUL WITH
THE CRITERIA THAT DOCTOR MONTH
ON YOUR WILL OUTLINE. AND
QUICKLY. IN SERVICE TEACHERS
MANY STUDENT TEACHERS THAT INTO
THE FIELD INTERESTED IN TEACHING
I THINK STUDIES IF THEY HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE SOCIAL PROTEST SIGNS
CREDENTIAL THERE DISTRICTS ARE
WORKING WITH LOCAL UNIVERSITIES
ENTITIES ORGANIZATIONS I THINK
WE'VE HEARD A MARAT OF EXAMPLES
ALREADY OF THE TYPE OF
COLLABORATIONS- THAT ARE
HAPPENING VIA CERTIFICATIONS OR
THAT COULD BE IT COULD HAPPEN.
MISTER TYPICALLY-
DESERTIFICATION WITH RESPECT TO
OUR- TEACHERS WORKING WITH- THE
THOMAS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SPECIFICALLY WITH FOURTH FIFTH
EIGHTH AND NINTH GRADERS-
LOOKING AT THE EXPERIENCES THERE
FROM GROUNDED IN ETHNIC STUDIES
AND THIS ALSO INCLUDES ETHNIC
STUDIES PROFESSORS SO AT
THIRTIES PROGRAMS- PARTY
CRITICAL AND THE COLLABORATION
IS NECESSARY BETWEEN ETHNIC
STUDIES AND TEACH CHRISTIAN
PROGRAM. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ONCE THE PANELS
COMPLETED. THANK YOU NOW WILL GO
TO THE THIRD PALACE THAT AS A
ONE THANK YOU. FOR SAW- THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT PANEL TODAY- AS MY TO
GET IT THE SAID I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE HEARD TODAY THAT. A STATE
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU MY CALL
WAS INTO TO CATIA. FOR OF THEM
TRYING TO. WITHIN THE YEAR PRO.
FIX THE DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE-
AND THAT IS THE OF QUALIFIED
ETHNIC STUDIES OF TEACHERS UP
AND THE CARD. DEVELOPING SOME
WONDERFUL PROGRAMS TO PLAY CATCH
UP. LET ME JUST SAY YOU KNOW I
ACTUALLY OF THE BILL AS WELL A
TEACHER AT KATE. WITHIN.
OR I COULD TEACH AND SHE GONNA
STUDIES. AND THE AND I CHOSE TO
GO ON A STUDIES- MAINLY BECAUSE
RUDY OF KONYA MANY OF YOU KNOW.
OFTEN REMINDED US THAT TO KIND
OF CITIES FACULTY. IT IS OUR
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE FUTURE
TEACHERS. IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES AND UNDERSTAND OUR OUR
STUDENTS. UP THE FOUNDING THAT
YOU GOT IS THAT EASY OFTEN SAID.
COINCIDED WITH THE CALL FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND SO WE
ARE NOT NEW TO TEACHER
PREPARATION AND I COULD SAY THE
SAME ABOUT MY SIMPLY IN A
DEPARTMENT OF AN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER STUDIES
AFRICANA STUDIES AMERICAN INDIAN
STUDIES WE ALL WE- BEEN-
INTERESTING TO ME UNLESS TO THE-
TODAY YES WHAT A DISK CAN THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN COLLEGES OF
EDUCATION. OUR STATE SYSTEMS
UNDER ETHNIC STUDIES DEPARTMENT
ALL WHICH SHOULD BE WORKING
JOINTLY IN THE PREPARATION OF
ETHNIC STUDIES TEACHERS. WE FOR
EXAMPLE WHERE THE MONEY THE
FIRST TO GET PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SESSIONS IN ETHNIC
STUDIES AND HISTORY AND LANGUAGE
AND CULTURE ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INITIATED PROGRAMS
LIKE OPERATION SHE GOT A TEACHER
AT CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE. THE
BLACK TECH ON FRIDAY GRAHAM
POSTED LA THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
EDUCATION PROJECT AT SAC STATE
THE FILIPINO EDUCATION PROGRAM
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE WHERE WE
IN ETHNIC STUDIES PROVIDED
INTERNSHIPS TO LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GAVE PROSPECTIVE
TEACHERS EXPERIENCES IN
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT. PROVIDED
MONETARY STIPENDS AND EARLY
FILLED. IN SCHOOLS AND INCOME
WORKING WITH PARENTS. THESE
PROGRAMS WERE OFTEN SUPPORTED BY
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING OR BY
GRANTS AND ALL OF THEM
UNFORTUNATELY EVENTUALLY SAW
THEIR DEMISE BUT THE DESIRE AND
THE DETERMINATION TO CONTINUE.
TO PROVIDE OUR FUTURE TEACHERS
TO TEACH THE CONTENT THE PISTA
MALIK G. THE LINGUISTIC
REPERTOIRE THE INTELLECTUAL
TRADITIONS THE ART AND CULTURE
THE. PEDIG PRACTICES IN ETHNICS
THE AS A CO AREA REMAINED INTACT
UNTIL I ABSOLUTELY STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT EVERY SINGLE
DISCIPLINE AND EVERY SINGLE
MAJOR SHOULD INFUSE EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
PRINCIPLES IN THEIR MAJOR THAT
EVERY SINGLE PROGRAM DEPARTMENT
AND- OFFICE WITHIN A SEAT WHEN
YOU SEE SHOULD EXEMPLIFIED
JUSTICE AND EQUITY AND DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION IN THEIR OPERATION
AND FUNCTIONS. THAT IS NOT
ETHNIC STUDIES ETHNIC STUDIES IS
VERY DIFFERENT. AND AT THE
PRESENT TIME ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENTS CONTINUED TO OFFER
PROGRAMS IN TEACHER PREPARATION
VERY FEW OF WHICH WERE NAMED
TODAY. SAN FRANCISCO STATE CAL
STATE LA AND SEE SON DO IT
THROUGH PROGRAMS THAT MEET THE
STATE STANDARDS FOR THE TEACHING
PROFESSION SO THERE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE HAD TO GO THROUGH THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING THIS BUDGET MATTER
PROGRAMS THAT MUCH THAT THE
MULTITUDE THAT TALKED ABOUT. IT
WAS STUDENT FOUR THREE MAJORS
INTO KIND OF STUDIES WITH THE
SINGLE SUBJECT MATTER MAJOR THEN
THEY WILL AUTOMATICALLY BE
ALLOWED TO GO INTO IT DID YOU
SING PROGRAM WITHOUT A SEIZE
THAT THE SAME APPLIES FOR THE
ETHNIC STUDIES PROGRAM. AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE. TO AND THAT MAY
BE IN QUESTION AFTER THE PAST OF
THE BUDGET BILL OF AB ONE THIRTY
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THEIR SINGLE SUBJECT
MAJORS. LIKE TO KNOW MY- FINGERS
HILLS AND EAST BAY. ARE WORKING
THROUGH EXISTING LIBERAL STUDIES
PROGRAMS THAT PREPARE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHERS SO SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU HEARD TODAY
LIKE THE L. CAL STATE LA
PROGRAM. IS NOT PREPARED MEANS
THE TEACHERS TO TEACH HIGH
SCHOOL ETHNIC STUDIES. THERE ARE
ACTUALLY PREPARING TEACHERS TO
TEACH ELEMENTARY ETHNIC STUDIES.
WHICH IS NEAT BUT NOT IS NOT A-
AB ONE OH ONE. AT THE SEVEN WE
HAVE COURSES WITH IN OUR
DEPARTMENT THAT MEET THE B.
CLASS STANDARDS WE HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE TWELVE TO
THIRTEEN COURSES IN EDUCTION IN
CHICANO STUDIES. AND MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS TAKE THE CHECK ON A
CHILD CLASS THE LANGUAGE
ACQUISITION CLASS AND OTHERS TO
MEET THE B. CLASS CERTIFICATE SO
WE HAVE THE COURSE WORK. BUT YET
WHEN MY STUDENTS COME INTO MY
CORPUS MANY IN THEIR SENIOR YEAR
THEY LET ME THE FACT THEY ARE
NOT READY TO. START RIGHT ONE MY
COURT AND ONE YEAR IS NOT GOING
TO PREPARE THEM TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES- AND I CAN GO ON THAT
LIST OTHER CAMPUSES DOING ETHNIC
STUDIES WORK IN THE AREA OF
TEACHER PREPARATION BUT LET ME.
WITH THIS. AND IN NINETEEN AND-
TWENTY. UP CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND THAT FRESNO
COLLEGE OF EDUCATION CRIME AND-
THROUGH BUT THEY SAID LOPEZ. CO
SPONSORED A SERIES OF WEBINARS
ON ETHNIC STUDIES TEACHER
PATHWAY PROJECTS. PROVIDING MANY
OF THE FOLKS THAT YOU HEARD THIS
AFTERNOON TO PRESENT THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT T. CATION AND
ETHNIC STUDIES. BUT THERE WOULD
BE PREPARED WITH THE AB ONE
REQUIREMENT. WE HAVE OVER A ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PARTICIPANTS
REPRESENTING K. TWELVE EDUCATORS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL BOARD TRUSTEES COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND UNION ORGANIZERS THE
COMPLETED SURVEYS AND
PARTICIPATED IN THIS WEAPON ARE.
AND HERE'S THEIR FINDINGS.
CURRENT SUBJECTS ARE PROJECTS
THAT EXIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONLY THREE HAVE
ETHNIC STUDIES SPECIALIST IN
THOSE CALIFORNIA SUBJECT MATTER
PROJECTS WHAT WE NEED ARE ETHNIC
STUDIES SUBJCT MATTER PROJECTS
TO OVERWHELMINGLY CONSENSUS FROM
EXPERTS AND PARTICIPANTS THAT
MULTICULTURAL EDUCATION AND
ETHNIC STUDIES IS THE SAME.
THREE THERE IS A STRONG
FOUNDATION AND THAT'S NEXT THAT
IS NON NEGOTIABLE FOR THE
PREPARATION OF FUTURE TEACHERS.
THERE IS SOCIAL STUDIES
CREDENTIAL IS NOT ENOUGH. AND
THAT ONE YEAR DOES NOT EQUAL THE
OF A STRONG FOUNDATION IN ETHNIC
STUDIES WE DO FEEL THAT THERE
ARE THAT THERE HAS TO BE OF VERY
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS. DESIGNED
FOR CURRENT MAJORS AND ETHNIC
STUDIES TO GET THEIR TEACHING
CREDENTIAL WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
DO WHAT MY TO GET IT THE SAID
WHICH IS THAT MEET ADDITIONAL
COURSEWORK. TO A UNIVERSITY
AUTHORIZATION THAT WOULD OFFER A
DEGREE IN ANY OF THE DISCIPLINES
OF ETHNIC STUDIES AND THEN A
CREDENTIAL- A CERTIFICATE
PROGRAM AND STE CURRENTLY SAN
FRANCISCO STATE AND YESTERDAY
THANK. NORTHRIDGE APPROVED A
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM FOR
PRACTICING EDUCATORS- THAT WOULD
BE TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES AND
THAT THAT CERTIFICATE PROGRAM
HAS THREE COURSES IN THE CONTENT
AREA ONE COURSE IN SPECIFIC
PEDAGOGY ANDONE COURSE IN FIELD
EXPERIENCE WHERE THEY WOULD-
TEACHER. THE THIRD IS THE
POSSIBILITY OF DISTRICT MICRO
CREDENTIAL AUTHORIZATIONS WERE
DISTRICTS ETHNIC STUDIES FACULTY
AND COLLEGE OF EDUCATION WOULD
WORK TOGETHER AND DESIGNING OF
MICRO CREDENTIALS WITH AT LEAST
80% OF THE CONTENT KNOWLEDGE
BEING AN ETHNIC STUDIES. AND
FINALLY WHAT YOU ALL CAN HELP US
TO DO. IS TO REALLY HELP SUPPORT
ETHNIC STUDIES PATHWAY PILOT
PROJECTS SIMILAR TO THE PROJECTS
THAT YOU ONCE HAD OR THAT MAYBE
STILL EXIST THE CAREER LADDER
OPTIONS THAT THAT THE STATE
OFFERED WHERE THERE WAS FUNDING
FOR PILOT PROJECTS- FOR.
EDUCATORS WHO WANT TO ACHIEVE
THEIR TEACHING CREDENTIAL TO
OFFERS SUCH- OF A PATH WITH A
PILOT PROJECT THAT WOULD REQUIRE
ETHNIC STUDIES FACULTY COLLEGES
OF EDUCATION DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY TO BEGIN TO THINK OF
WAYS TO CREATE. A PATHWAY FOR A
GROW YOUR UP AS MY COLLEAGUE- AT
RIVERSIDE SAID. I THINK CITY
TEACHERS ARE MAY THEY'RE NOT
WORN. I THINK EDUCATORS MUST
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF THE ETHNIC
STUDIES CONTENT AND SUBJECT
MATTER AND A STRONG GRASP OF
ETHNIC STUDIES PEDAGOGY.
ULTIMATELY WE ALL HAVE THE
ETHICAL RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
THAT THE DISCIPLINE OF ETHNIC
STUDIES IS PROVIDED THE SAME
ACADEMIC DEFERENCE AS MATH. AND
SCIENCE AS ENGLISH AS OUR- IN AN
EFFORT TO MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY
OF ETHNIC STUDIES AND TO CREATE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS FOR ALL
STUDENTS CAN ENGAGE IN CRITICAL
CONVERSATIONS TAKE ACADEMIC
RISKS AND LEARN TO THINK
CRITICALLY WELL BECOMING MORE
COMPASSIONATE. AND EMPATHETIC
INDIVIDUALS COLLEGES OF
EDUCATION ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENTS THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
COMMUNITY WAS JOINED TOGETHER IN
A JOINT ENDEAVOR TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE- SHE OUR CHILDREN WHEN
WE IMPLEMENT QUALITY ETHNIC
STUDIES PROGRAMS AND COURSES.
THANK YOU DR MANTEGNA I'M GONNA
START WITH- SHARING THE TWO
WEEKS AGO I WAS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE CAMPUS AT A MEMORIAL
SERVICE FOR ONE OF MY PROFESSORS
BY PROFESSOR OF- TO KIND OF
POLITICS A DOCTOR MON THE NEVADA
WHO WHO PASSED AWAY RECENTLY.
AND WE HAVE SAID IS CHAMBER OVER
AND OVER AGAIN WE'VE HEARD IT
FROM STUDENTS FROM PHD STUDENTS
FROM HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS FROM
OUR OWN COLLEAGUES FROM MR LOW
MR SANTIAGO THE POWER OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. AND SO AS THE MEMORIAL
FOR DOCTOR MON THE NEVADA TOOK
PLACE TWO WEEKS GO AT UC
RIVERSIDE THE THEATER AT UCR WAS
FULL FULL OF STUDENTS.
GENERATIONS OF STUDENTS. FROM
FOLKS AS OLD AS MAY TWO YOUNGER
FOLKS LIKE EDUARDO GARCIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND YOUNGER BUT
WE ALL HAD THE SAME STORY THE
SAME MESSAGE AND I WAS HERE JUST
A LITTLE BIT THAT WHEN I WAS
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD AND- IN MY
SENIOR YEAR AT UC RIVERSIDE AND
I SAT AND DOCTOR MON THEN ABOUT
HIS CLASS- WHERE I.TEXTBOOK WAS
OCCUPIED AMERICA. IN THE FIRST
ADDITION THAT THEY STILL HAVE-
THE IMPACT THAT THAT HAD ON US
AS STUDENTS. AND ESPECIALLY AS
LATINO CHICANO STUDENTS RIGHT IT
INSPIRED THIS AND I SAID I'VE
SAID DR. BOTTAS FOR THE FIRST
TIME NOT ONLY FROM THE PAGES OF
DOCTOR GUNAS BOOK BUT ALSO BY
HIS EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW THAT WE-
WERE VALUE. THAT WE HAD A
HISTORY AND A CULTURE THAT WAS
OF VALUE THAT HAD BEEN IGNORED
BUT BUT NO LESS. IMPORTANT. AND
THAT HE BELIEVED IN US AS
STUDENTS AND AS AS SCHOLARS AND
THEREFORE STUDENTS FROM THAT
CLASS WENT ON TO BE TEACHERS
LIKE MYSELF. ATTORNEYS LIKE
CARLOS WHY THOSE JUDGES LIKE
WHAT A HERNANDEZ. RIGHT AND SO
THE IMPACT. IS UNDENIABLE RIGHT
WHEN DONE RIGHT. SO HERE WE ARE
. ALMOST FIFTY YEARS LATER FROM
THAT THE TIME THAT I WAS A
STUDENT A SENIOR AT UC RIVERSIDE
SITTING IN DR NEVADA'S CLASS AND
WE HAVE NOW PASSED THIS
LEGISLATION WE HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE. OR INSTITUTIONS WHO WANT
TO GO AND BECOME TEACHERS AND
BECAUSE CATION CAN BE
TRANSFORMED WITH THIS WE SEE THE
SHORTAGE OF TEACHERS OF COLOR.
WE SEE TEACHERS OF COLOR
DROPPING OUT OF. LEAVING THE
CLASSROOM BECAUSE THEY'RE FACED
WITH OBSTACLES THAT OTHER
TEACHERS DON'T IT'S- SO I THINK
ONE QUESTION THAT I HAVE- FOR
ALL THE THREE PANELISTS HERE IS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING AT YOUR
INSTITUTIONS OF THE FOLKS WHO
ARE LOOKING TO BECOME TEACHERS
AND- YOU KNOW HOW MANY. ARE ARE
BEING ATTRACTED TO WANTING TO
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES WHAT ARE
YOU SEEING ON YOUR CAMPUSES.
WELL I CAN TELL YOU THAT ARE
SINGLE SUBJECT MAJOR HAS DOUBLED
RIGHT IN THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THAT ARE COMING INTO A PROGRAM.
OF THAT THE CERTIFICATE OPTION
IN- ETHNIC STUDIES THAT WAS
PASSED YOU WITHOUT ONE
DISSENTING VOTE AND THE ACADEMIC
SENATE- FOR THE ACADEMIC
COUNCIL- BECAUSE THERE WAS A
STATE IT NEEDED. THAT WE HAVE
GOTTEN LEAST TWENTY INQUIRIES
AND JUST OVERNIGHT- FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE WANTING TO ENROLL IN
THAT CERTIFICATE- I WHEN I
STARTED AT- CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE
AND TOP THE COURSES IN ETHNIC
STUDIES OF MY COURSES WERE ABOUT
THIRTY STUDENTS- AT THE DICK.
TEN SOME AND BUSINESS OF BECAUSE
THERE WEREN'T THERE WAS NO ONE
WHO WANTED TO GO INTO EDUCATION
AND NOW WE OFFER FORCE THIS- AND
THE CLASSES ARE PACKED- AND MORE
STUDENTS TO ENROLL SO THAT I
MEAN I TELL MY STUDENTS WERE
ADVISED. VISIT RIGHT TO BE. I'M
SURE AN ETHNIC STUDIES. OF THEIR
COMING IN AT THE MERCY WAS
PERFECT TIME SO THE INTERESTS IS
ABSOLUTELY GOING UP. AND WHAT
YOU AND DOING LOUIS DID YOU
WANNA GO FIRST OR YOU WANT ME TO
GO SURE I COULD JUMP IN- IT
WORST TEAM IS ON AVERAGE. ABOUT
A HUNDRED THIRTY STUDENTS PER
COHORT. PER YEAR OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS. AND WHAT WERE SEEN
SINCE WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THE
ETHNIC STUDIES PATHWAY AN
EMPHASIS- ALMOST 20% OF THOSE
STUDENTS HAVE SOME KIND OF
INTEREST IN. ETHNIC STUDIES A
MINUTE STUDIES- ENGINE WHAT I'M
OBSERVING IT. THIS IS COMING
THEY'RE COMING TO US WITH
INTENTIONALITY WITH INTEREST
WITH A PASSION TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND I THINK THIS IS
AS MY COLLEAGUE JUST MENTIONED-
WHAT WE'RE SEEING AN INCREASE IN
INTEREST AND- I THINK THIS IS
NOT THE PERFECT TIME TO REALLY-
WRAP UP THESE EFFORTS TO
INCREASE THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEM TO. SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES
IN THESE WAYS. NOT PRIVATE THANK
YOU- I WOULD HAVE TO AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL I. HAVE
THE NUMBERS OF OUR CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS IN THE SUB SPECIFICALLY
ARE. I THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH
FACULTY TO ACTUALLY MEET THE
NEEDS OF- HOW MANY STUDENTS
WASHY ONE COMING TO THE PROGRAM.
AND SINCE WE'VE MADE BEGAN TO
THE INTENTIONAL EFFORTS OF
HAVING THAT LAYS ON BRIDGE
BETWEEN ETHNIC STUDIES AND
MYSELF AND SEE IF THERE. ARE
NUMBERS HAVE INCREASED AS WELL
AS FAR AS- AT THIS POINT TO
STUDENTS WANTED TO BE SOCIAL
SCIENCE MAJORS OR CREDENTIAL IN
TO BE ABLE TO CHECK STUDIES.
THAT'S POOL THERE. BECAUSE THAT
. WAY THAT EXIT. SO THAT NUMBER
INCREASED IN. IN THE IN THE- TO
REALLY. FOR AN EDUCATION THAT
WAS NOT GIVEN TO THAT. RIGHT NOW
BUT- IS ME AND I'M GOING TO AND
I THINK YOU HEARD IT AND I'M
SORRY BUT WAS VERY PASSIONATE IN
MY TIME BUT WE'LL WORRY ARE THE
STRUCTURES THAT CURRENTLY EXIST.
AT LEAST IN BUT I'M SEEN AS A
MENTAL STATE THAT ARE BEING USED
THAT IS UTILIZED RIGHT NOW AS
THE GATEKEEPERS AFTER MAKE MUCH
BIGGER. EVEN MORE TO BE NOTHING
THAT THANK. THANK WHEN AS CHAIR
BY DOCUMENT DANIEL THIS IS A
DISK. IN IN OF ITS WHY IS IT
BEING TREATED SO DIFFERENTLY SO
THAT B. R. IT IT. ALL I DO I DO
WANT TO ADD THE THAT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STUDENTS THAT
COME IN- FOR EIGHT ECONOMIST
MADE HIS ALSO CHANGE OF THERE IS
THE FACT THAT EVERYONE WHO IS
SHE GOT A- INCREASING. WHAT THE
MEN AND WANT TO TEACH THE AREA.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM- THE
DALLAS. COMMITTEE NOW. YES MR
GABRIEL. YES THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I HAVE TO SAY YOU
ARE A SUCH A GOOD REPRESENTATIVE
OF YOUR COMMUNITY I'M NOT
SURPRISED THAT WE HAVE SOME YOU
THE RIVER SO THERE. WELL IN
FRONT. I THOUGHT PROVOKING-
TESTIMONY TODAY I JUST WANT TO
SHARE A FEW REMARKS BECAUSE I'M
GONNA HAVE TO RUN OUT IN A
SECOND I WAS REFLECTING A LITTLE
BIT ON WHAT I. AND ON. CONRAD
HAS WORKED WELL FOR US- AND
WHERE WE'VE RUN INTO CHALLENGES
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE HEARD TODAY. THAT I'VE
ACTED ON A LOT IS. BRINGING THE
DIVERT THEIR THE BROADEST
DIVERSITY OF VOICES INTO THE
PROCESS AS WE THINK ABOUT THIS-
THAT BRINGING PEOPLE FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND PROCESS- I HAVE
TRIED. THIS REVERENCE. FOR
ALL OF WHOM HAVE WORKED IN OUR
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. AND I
WAS THINKING OF YOUR DOCTOR
OPERATIVE MI MY GRANDFATHER
SPENT- MANY DECADES ATTACK
STATUS- AND WAS ACTIVE IN THE
HEALTHCARE FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
AND HE CAME TO SAC STATE- HE
CAME FROM AN IMMIGRANT FAMILY OF
NO MONEY HE GRADUATED WITH FULL
SCHOLARSHIP WITH GREEN ENGINE
AND YORK. FINALLY A- KNOWN.
FUTURE CAME UP THE WEST COAST
SIR PROPERTY AND HIS ENTIRE AT
CSU AND IT WAS- I JUST FEEL SO
PASSIONATE BECAUSE I ASKED
BEYOND TIRED COMMITTEE THE ROLE
. THAT ARE STATE THE SYSTEM PLUS
- IN BRINGING PEOPLE INTO THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND SERVING AS AN
ENGINE OF SOCIAL MOBILITY
PREPARING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK IF. IMPORTANT
PEOPLE- BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
WE GOT TO HAVE A BROAD DIVERSE
ARRAY OF FOLKS AND WHEN WE HAVE
GOTTEN GOOD CURRICULUM. THE
MODEL CAR THE PEOPLE HAVE FELT
ABOUT THE DELORES HUERTA SHIRLEY
WEBER LEADERS FOR COMPANY
COMMUNITIES. ABOUT ITS BECAUSE
WE WANT A LOT OF WAYS WE'VE GOT
A LOT PLACES IN DON'T. FROM
DIFFERENT. WHAT THE TO STAR HOW
WE CONSTRUCT A ON THAT WERE FOR
THIS EXCEPT A DIVERSE STATE THAT
WE LIVE IN- WITH PEOPLE FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD SPEAK UP OF LIKE
AND ALL THE KINDS BACK ON SINCE
YOU KNOW BEING THE SON. THE
GREAT ACADEMIC I'M ALSO FROM THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE. ARGUMENTS
WITH THE POINTS I THINK ABOUT
THE- X. OF MY- OWN WHO'S ABOUT
PROFESSOR USE JUST. WHO FOR. A
LOT ON HOW DO WE TEACH MATH AND
R. K. TWELVE. RATE ARGUMENT IN
THE CASE. BETWEEN TENSIONERS
BETWEEN I COULD ABOUT THE MOST
UP WAY HOW SHOULD WE TEACH MATH
AND YOU KNOW CERTAIN THINGS
ABOUT MATH OR ARE INDISPUTABLE
BUT THE- HOW DO YOU TEACH THE
DIVERSE STATE. HARSTAD IN THEIR
NUMBERS IN OUR PEOPLE COMING TO
THE TABLE SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE'RE INCLUDING OUR
FACULTY I THINK WE- THE BROADEST
GROUP PROPERTY POSSIBLE BUT I
ALSO INCLUDE A LOT STAKEHOLDERS
AND WE- BOTH OF IT. WE HAVE. IN
TWO THE DIVERSITY OUR STATE
THAT'S HOW I GET THE STRAW
PROPONENTS WOULD JUST OFFER THAT
AS MY PERSPECTIVE AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU SHARE FOR THE CURRENT
I THANK THE WITNESSES AS WELL.
IT IT IT JUST ON THE- LITTLE BIT
FEARS DAY GABRIEL AND THINK ONE
OF. THE STRENGTHS OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. IS THAT. AS A
DISCIPLINE BECAUSE WHERE IT CAME
. THAT FROM THE BOTTOM UP YOU
KNOW ETHNIC STUDIES WAS A- A
CRITIQUE ON OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM A CRITIQUE OF THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THAT WAS IN
PLACE AND IT IS. PUBLIC
EDUCATION BEGAN AND IT WAS A
CRITIQUE SAYING THAT CERTAIN
GROUPS HAD BEEN OMITTED. AND
CERTAIN FOLKS HISTORIES AND
VALUES HAD BEEN A MINUTE SO
BECAUSE IT COMES FROM THE BOTTOM
UP INHERENTLY AN ETHNIC STUDIES
THEREIS THAT OF INCLUDING THE
CAN. AS WE- WE'RE AT ALL LEVELS
OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES AND THEN
AS WE GO TO IMPLEMENT- ETHNIC
STUDIES I THINK WE WOULD WOULD
HEAR FROM ALL OUR OTHER
EDUCATIONAL FOLKS THAT THE
COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO BEING
INCLUDED AND SO WHEN I TURN YOUR
CHOI I SAID THE- I. CAUGHT ON
DOCTOR CHECK- TO COME AND SPEAK
TO OUR USD IT WASN'T SO MUCH
BECAUSE OF HIS ACADEMIC AND HE
DIDN'T EVEN COME FROM IT- AT
FROM THAT DIRECTION IT WAS
BECAUSE HE WAS ALSO FOR THE
COMMUNITY. AND YOU KNOW I WENT
TO A CONGRESSMAN TO CONDOS
MOTHER NANCY TO KHAN WHO PASSED
AWAY SOON AFTER THE MEETING AND
NANCY TOCADO CON THE CONDOS- MOM
HAD BEEN IN THE INTERMENT YOU
KNOW HAD BEEN ENTERED DURING THE
WORLD WAR TWO SHE HAD THE
HISTORY OF HAVING LIVED IN THE
CAPS SO THE ONE OF THE STRENGTH
THAT IS TO GROUP. THAT THAT IS
DRAWS UPON THE COMMUNITY AND THE
COMMUNITY'S HISTORY. IN WHAT IS
TAUGHT- SO THAT'S KIND OF IN HER
INHERENT IN ETHNIC STUDIES AND
JUST JUST TO SHARE THE- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS MR BLOW. NOW I
WOULD ASK THE QUESTION- THAT YOU
GET YOU BROUGHT OUT I THINK- DR
I WILL LET YOU BROUGHT OUT. THE
T. DEGREE T. AN ETHNIC STUDIES
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT. TO
BECOME A TEACHER. BUT SOMETIMES
DEPENDING IF YOU DON'T HAVE. OF
FOR EXAMPLE AT NORTHRIDGE THEY
HAVE THE SUBJECT MATTER
AUTHORIZATION THROUGH ETHNIC
STUDIES RIGHT. AT SACRAMENTO
THAT'S NOT THE CASE AND SO IF A
STUDENT IS AN ETHNIC STUDIES
MAJOR AND WANTS TO ENSURE THE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL PROGRAM THEY
HAVE TO SHOW SOME MATTER
COMPETENCY BUT THAT'S NOT I
DIDN'T SEE. NOW IS SOCIAL
SCIENCE. IT SO THEN NOT ONLY
WITH THEY HAVE TO. TAKE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THEIR OWN MAJOR
RIGHT BUT THEN THEY WOULD HAVE
TO ALSO TAKE ALL THE COURSES.
THAT THIS DANCE DISCIPLINE SAYS
IS NECESSARY TO SHOW SOCIAL
SCIENCE COMPETENCY. AND SO
THAT'S WHERE I THINK YOU SEE THE
EQUITY RESPECT TO THE LEVEL OF
WORK THAT AN ETHNIC STUDIES
MAJOR. PASSED YOU THINK THAT
SOMEONE WILL SET A PERFECT WAS A
JUST A POWERFUL THING SHE SAYS
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS. COULD NOT
LOOK THAT AS OR DO IN THE SAME
WAY AS- ENGLISH AS DID THE OTHER
DIFFERENT SUBJECT MATTERS AND
THAT IS WHAT HAS. MY WHAT I'VE
BEEN FIGHTING FOR RIGHT NOW YOU
KNOW OUR CAMPUS AND ACROSS THE
STATE AS WE CONTINUE TO ORGANIZE
COLLECTIVELY AND HOPEFULLY
FORMING- WHICH IS THAT IF
SOMEONE VALUES IDEA OF A
CONSORTIUM BETWEEN. COLLEGES
PROFESSORS IN TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND PROFESSORS
THAT MAKE STUDIES TO RUDY- MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S THAT
INTERSECTION ALITY THAT EXISTS.
IT STUDENT SITE IT'S TOO MUCH
COURSE WORK IT'S GOING TO EXTEND
MY STATE IT'S GOING TO I'M GONNA
BE HERE FIVE SIX YEARS IF I HAVE
TO DO ALL THIS ISSUE DON'T CATCH
THEM EARLY ENOUGH- TO BE ABLE
TO. TO HAVE THOSE COURSES THEN-
THEY HAVE TO TAKE THE C. SET.
AND THE C. SAID BUT- FOR MANY-
BY PARKS WOULDN'T. HAS BEEN VERY
BIAS WITH RESPECT TO THAT- AND
THE CONTENT AS I SHARED IN MY
STATEMENT DOES NOT NECESSARILY
REFLECT THE DISCIPLINE WHICH
THEY WERE. THAT THEY STUDIED IN
WHICH WAS ETHNIC STUDIES AND
IT'S COSTLY AND SO THERE'S ALL
THESE DIFFERENT- IS THAT COME
INTO PLAY THAT I THINK THAT Y. I
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT MY OPINION
THAT UP AND- I. MY CALL CRISIS.
COMPACT ARE SHARING THE POWERFUL
WHAT THE HAPPENING EVEN ON ALL
CAMPUS THE POWERFUL WORK THAT'S
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT WE FOR THE- AT
THE SAME. WE HAVE TO PUSH- SEE.
THAT COULD BE THE BY ALL OF YOU
. AND IT WOULD HIGHLY. THAT I
THINK IT INTEREST. THAT THE
RIVERS THAT DOCTOR AVILA IS NOT
TRUE THAT I HEARD FROM FROM THE
COMMISSION ON CREDENTIALING THAT
. THAT THEY WOULD ASSUME THAT IF
YOU HAVE THE SOCIAL STUDIES
CREDENTIAL YOU HAVE THE
EXPERTISE TO DO JUST THAT ETHNIC-STUDIES BUT IF YOU HAVE THE
ETHNIC STUDIES CREDENTIAL YOU
HAVE TO PROVE. THAT THANK YOU
CAN TEACH SOCIAL STUDIES SO
EXACTLY YEAH I GET IT AND WE CAN
HAVE A WHOLE OTHER CONVERSATION
ON THAT OR NOT WELL THAT SHOWS
THAT SHOWS THERE'S A- REAL.
EXACTLY AT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE TO PASS. UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IT THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE AND- THAT WAS THE LAST
PANEL SO THEN WE WILL NOW OPEN
IT UP. TO PUBLIC COMMENT- AND
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS- LIMIT
LIMIT- PUBLIC COMMENTS TO TWO
MINUTES AND I HAVE MY TIMER HERE
. SO IF YOU WOULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND I WOULD START THE
TIMER FOR TWO MINUTES HE- YES
GOOD ACTORS DR MELISSA MORENO
AND I AM A COLLEAGUE OF MINE
ELECTED OFFICIAL FOR A COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION BUT I'M ALSO
MOST IMPORTANTLY A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. ETHNIC STUDIES FACULTY
AND SO I WOULD REALLY LIKE FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO REALLY KEEP IN
MIND THAT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM ONLY PAYS FOR STUDENTS
TO DO ONE MAJOR. FILL MY
STUDENTS HAVE TO DECIDE BETWEEN
AN ETHNIC STUDIES. RIGHT
8 DEGREES OR NON ETHNIC STUDIES
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT AND SO
RIGHT NOW THAT IS EIGHTY
CHAPTERS STRUGGLE IT RELATES TO
WHAT DOCTOR BET THEM OUT OF
FABULA IN SAINT ETHNIC STUDIES
RETAINS THEM. AND THAT'S HOW
THEY'RE ABLE TO SUCCEED AT
PROCESS BUT YOU GET THEY HAVE A
LOT IN THE- IN FRONT. OF THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE THERE ONLY GET
PAID. ONCE WE PETER PIPER THE MY
OF OUR STUDENTS STUDENTS OF
COLOR ARE AT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THEY NEED
A PATH IN UC'S. VIEW ARE WE
DEFINITELY NEED A COURSE IN
EDUCATION- ETHNIC STUDIES FOR
EDUCATORS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOR THAT TO BE A BRIDGE- WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT NOT ALL ETHNIC STUDIES- OUR
HISTORY PROJECTS ARE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO SERVE ALL OF THEIR-
COMMUNITY. SO IT IT'S REAL IN
TO. KEEP IN MIND ALSO THAT RIGHT
NOW COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
ARE NOT NECESSARILY SEEN OF
THEMSELVES AS BEING THE ONES
RESPONSIBLE FOR- THE CREDENTIALS
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENTS
FOR ALL OF THEIR A DISTRICTS
BECAUSE OF LOCAL CONTROL. COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION FOCUSES ON
CONTINUATION JUVENILE HALL
SPECIAL ED BUT THE LEAVE THAT
THE DISTRICTS ARE LIKE THEIR OWN
ENTITIES. SOMEONE WHO. YEAH
ADDRESS AROUND TEACHING
CREDENTIALS BUT THAT'S NOT
HISTORICALLY WHAT WHAT IT IS
WHAT IT'S BEEN THERE IS A MAJOR
AND THIS IS MY LAST POINT THERE
IS A MAJOR SEVERE TEACHER
SHORTAGE RIGHT NOW WE DEFINITELY
NEED FUNDING FOR EDUCATORS WE
CANNOT AFFORD FOR OUR OUR
STUDENTS RIGHT TO SAY I'M NOT
GOING TO MAJOR IN ETHNIC STUDIES
AND NOT GOING TO BE A TEACHER
BECAUSE MY HEALTH CARE AND
HOUSING I WILL BE ABLE COVERED.
BY B. IN A ONE YEAR TEACHER WE
DEFINITELY TO INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR ART TEACHERS
TEACHING AND THE ARE THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING ALL OF
THESE ARE POINTS THANK YOU. DR
GOOD AFTERNOON- THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN THE MEDINA AND-
COMMITTEE. OF MY NEAREST DOCTOR
BARBER FOR LETTUCE AND I WEAR
MANY HATS UP. A SIR AMERICANIST
THIRTY TWO YEARS AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SAN BERNARDINO
AND I WAS A BE CLAD PROFESSOR. I
AM A PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA LET YOUR SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION AND- I AM
CURRENTLY THE PRESIDENT I'M
RETIRED PRESIDENT OF COPY. BUT
THE MOST IMPORTANT POSITION THAT
I HOLD RIGHT NOW IS THAT I'M AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL I MEAN SCHOOL.
SOMEBODY FROM SOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL SAID THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT LEFT OUT YOU'VE LEFT
US OUT THIS THE GOVERNING BOARDS
OF THE STATE WHO ARE CHARGED
WITH WOMEN TEAM THANKS STUDIES.
AND SO WE NEED PEOPLE THAT ARE
QUALIFIED WE NEED PEOPLE THAT
HAVE CONTENT KNOWLEDGE OF ETHNIC
STUDIES IN THE MEANTIME WE NEED
PEOPLE TO HAVE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SO SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE MADE
REGARDING HAVING SEARCH. AND
WEBER- COLLEAGUE ARE DOCTOR
TENNIS TINY WRECK. THAT YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE FIVE COURSES I MEAN
THERE'S A MODEL THERE LET'S USE
OUT CTC HAS TO STEP UP TO THE
PLATE. OUR TO UP YOU KNOW. WHAT
ARE THE CRITERIA FOR THE SUBJECT
MATTER- COMPETENCIES ALL SIX
THIRTY SCHOLARS AND PROFESSORS
IN PROGRAMS AND- DEPARTMENTS OF
THE FIX CITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AS EVIDENCED BY OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN KNOWLEDGE.
WE HAVE JOINTLY NUMBER WORK WITH
. CREATE THIS PASSED THE SERVICE
FOR THAT UP WITH MY CAR- DOCTOR
LOU RODRIGUEZ- MENTIONED THEY
HAVE PATHWAYS WELL THOSE
PATHWAYS ARE IMPORTANT BUT ALSO
IMPORTANT IN OUR- LOOKED
LOCATION WE HAVE TO ALSO. BEGIN
TO HAVE PASSED HE'S IN OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS AS WELL FOR OUR KIDS AND
OUR KIDS ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
FIX STUDIES THEY ARE DOWNEY. TO
KNOW ABOUT THEMSELVES ABOUT
THEIR HISTORIES ABOUT. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW. ONCE YOU KNOW
WHO YOU ARE YOU CAN YOU CAN.
WELL IN THAT HISTORY IS. YOU CAN
. AND SO- I HIGHLY RECOMMEND
THAT THIS COMMITTEE I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU DO IT YOU'RE THE
LEGISLATORS DO YOU EIGHT
LEGISLATURE YOU TAP C. T. C.
THIS IS YOU HAVE TO. AT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS DR THERESA WILLIAMS LEON
AND- I'M ACTUALLY BOTH IN THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN STUDIES
DEPARTMENT BUT TODAY I'M HERE TO
SPEAK AS AN ASIAN AMERICAN STATE
FACULTY AT CAL STATE. AN MOTHER
FROM JAPAN AND A AN ELEVENTH
GENERATION EUROPEAN AMERICAN OF
MILITARY VETERAN FATHER I'M
MARRIED TO A MEXICAN AMERICAN
MAN OF WHO IS THE SON OF TO. ME
AND DOTTER I'M SAD TO SAY THAT
SHE'S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
BECAUSE SHE GRADUATES IN TWENTY
TWELVE FOR. I'M HERE WHO-
IMPRESSED UPON ALL OF YOU THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE VOICES OF
ETHNIC STUDIES- EDUCATORS
SCHOLARS PRACTITIONERS THOSE OF
US WHO ARE TRAINED IN AN ETHNIC
STUDIES. I COULD H. D. AND SO
BALAJI ON YOURS AND SOCIOLOGY
AND A MASTER'S IN ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES AT UCLA. AND ALSO A
TICKET THE.
S. OR AN ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES
PROFESSOR IT REALLY WAS THE
RESEARCH SKILLS THE CRITICAL
PEDAGOGY- AND THE
INTERDISCIPLINARY OF THE
TRAINING THAT I RECEIVED IN.
ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES ENOUGH
STUDIES. ANY UP WHO ARE AT STEP
PERFECT- VERY MUCH LIKE OUR OWN
STUDENTS WE ARE FOR. MANY OF US
ARE FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE-
DEMOCRATS. AND SO WE COME FROM
THE COMMUNITIES WE ARE THE
COMMUNITY MUCH LIKE OUR STUDENTS
SO I JUST WANTED TO IMPRESS UPON
ALL OVER AND I DID WANT TO SAY.
MY DEPARTMENT WE HAVE WITH THE-
AMERICAN STUDIES PATH TO SPUR.
THE ETHNIC STUDIES EDUCATION
PATHWAYS PROJECT WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH FACULTY ACROSS ETHNIC
STUDIES AS WELL AS IN EDUCATION-
AND SO I I'D LIKE IMPRESSED UPON
ALL OF YOU THAT- IN- IN. THOSE
OF US WHO ARE EDUCATORS AND
ETHNIC STUDIES- WHEN
IMPLEMENTING- YOU KNOW THE
TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES TEACHERS IN THE CAPE YOU
TWELVE INSTITUTION SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. GREETINGS JERRY
DINA ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
THIS IS THIS IS AN EXCITING
MOMENT OF SADDAM I DIDN'T EXPECT
TO BE SO ENERGIZED BY IT BUT I'M
GLAD I AM I'M NOT GONNA MORE.
AND STATION. ADDITIONALLY WHITE
STUDIES I SEE THAT DESCRIPTIVELY
SOME PEOPLE TAKE IT A DIFFERENT
WAY I WANT TO CLEAR THAT IT'S A
DESCRIPTIVELY AND HAPPEN NOTHING
STUDIES AS A PROFESSOR OF
PSYCHOLOGY AND H. CYCLE IN
TRADITIONALLY WHITE STUDIES
SAUSAGE OF WHITE I COLLEGES
PARKING PROUD OF IT. AN IT'S
ALSO A PROFESSOR I PROFESSOR OF
ETHNIC STUDIES AND THE FOR JUST
FORMER DEAN OF THE COLLEGE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES DISCUSSED.
FINALLY HERE ARE THE- CSU
COUNCIL OF THE SO- I COME HERE
NOT WITH ALL THOSE HATS ON. HIS
TWO ONE BUT- SO I COME AS A
COLLEAGUE BUT I WANT TO COME AS
A COLLEAGUE IN PUBLIC SERVICE
WHICH CONNECTS ALL OF US. AND I
WANT TO THE- D. CORE THEMES THAT
YOU'VE BEEN HEARING IN DRAWING
OUT OF PEOPLE. ARE IN THINKING
FROM A PUBLIC. EDUCATION
PERSPECTIVE FIRST K. ONE UNLIKE
COMMERCIAL VENDORS OF SAY ICE
CREAM OR CHEESE WHEN WE WERE
COMMISSIONED TO DELIVER ETHNIC
STUDIES OUR PRODUCT MUST BE WHAT
THE NAME SAYS OKAY IF YOU DID
YOUR STORE YOU KNOW SOMETIMES IT
IS SO THEREFORE ETHNIC STUDIES
MUST EXPERTS MUST VERIFY THAT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S NO
OTHER CONSULTATION WILL DO IT
EVERY DAY EVEN IF. THERE'S NOT A
GETS YEAH. NOT CAN. FOR YEARS-
SO THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE IT'S
GOING TO BE CONSULTED BUT YOU
BEST GREAT QUESTIONS THAT I
THINK SHOWED. A BIT OF- LACK OF
DEPTH AND CLARITY IN SOME
QUARTERS ON WHAT ETHNIC STUDIES
WAS IN A LACK OF ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
THAT THEY HAD TALKED TO ETHNIC
STUDIES. IT'S EVEN JUST OPENED
OUR CATALOGS AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF
CLASSES HUNDREDS. SO IT CAN'T BE
THIS THIS THIS ONLY AND IT'S A
DISCIPLINE IT'S NOT A TOPIC IT'S
NOT THE STUDY OF ETHNICITY. IT
IS THE DISCIPLINE BUILT. FROM
THE INTELLECTUAL TRADITIONS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS AND
ASPIRATIONS OF RACIALIZED
AMERICAN GROUPS OKAY. THAT OF
COURSE IS GOING TO BE DISCUSSED
I'M SURE. SO ANOTHER DIFFICULT
ONE FOR US TO GRAPPLE WITH HIS.
SOME INCLUDING ME MAY WANT MANY
WONDERFUL CHANGES IN THE
CURRICULUM K. THROUGH TWELVE.
AND WE HAVE AT LEAST SIXTY
COURSES K. TWELVE STUDENTS TAKE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE COURSE
IN ETHNIC STUDIES. I BELIEVE IT
INTELLECTUALLY. LIMITING AND A
RECIPE FOR FAILURE TO TRY TO
REMEDY EVERYTHING THAT THE
CURRENT TRADITIONALLY WHAT
STUDIES CURRICULUM DOESN'T DO IN
THAT ONE COURSE HOWEVER HE IS
THE PROMISE AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE WITH THE DISCIPLINE WAS
BORN. IT WAS BORN IT WAS BORN AS
A MULTI ETHNIC INCLUDING
PROGRESSIVE WHITES COALITION THE
DECIDED WHAT IT NEED TO BE AND
THEN ITS ENERGY BURST WOMEN'S
STUDIES QUEER STUDIES JEWISH
STUDIES PERSIAN STUDIES
DISABILITY STUDIES. IT GOES THE
OTHER WAY AROUND. YOU PLANT THE
FIRST SEED AND YOU GROW THE REST
OF THE PLANTS THE THIRD THIS IS
GOING TO BE CHALLENGING BECAUSE
WE'RE JUST STARTING. IT ALWAYS
IS GETTING BACK TO EXERCISE.
IT'S HARD BUT ETHNIC STUDIES
FACULTY HAVE ALREADY CREATED
MODELS OF TEACHING ETHNIC
STUDIES IN THE HIGH SCHOOL THEY
HAVE BEEN INDEPENDENTLY VERIFIED
AS NOT JUST GOOD INTELLECTUAL
QUALITY WHICH IS ALL IT REALLY
SHOULD HAVE TO PROMISE BUT AS
SUCCESS AS MOTIVATORS OF SUCCESS
AND ACHIEVEMENT FOR STUDENTS OF
ALL ETHNICITIES AND GENDERS
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT OTHERS
HAVE DONE SO WHAT DOES THE
QUESTION OF YOU CAN DO WITH
INSIGHT INTO THIS WHAT LANDFILLS
OF THE COURSE IS DOING WHAT THE-
COURSE IS DOING. SO ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNCIL OF ETHNIC STUDIES
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT
THAT THAT THAT'S THE LAST THING.
THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF COUNCIL
THAT THE STUDIES I'M HERE TO%
OFFER YOU THE FULL SUPPORT OF
OVER FIVE HUNDRED EXPERTS. THAT
YOU ALREADY SUPPORT
LEGISLATIVELY WHO ARE EXCITED
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU AND THEN. YEAH MISTER BLOOM
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I HAVE BELIEF
I KNOW THERE'S PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROBABLY WAY TO GIVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT- BY TELEPHONE- AND
UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T STAY FOR
THAT BUT I DID WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS VERY INFORMATIVE
HEARING- I'VE BEEN A SUPPORTER-
OF- THE ETHNIC STUDIES- A
PROPOSAL FROM FROM INCEPTION
FROM WHEN YOU FIRST CAME TO ME
AND SAID I WANT TALK ABOUT THE
STATE'S IMPORT- AND IT THINK I
DID- INTUITIVELY. AND IT IS
SAFER SO MANY KOREANS ARE A
BECAUSE THIS IS. I'M UNDERTAKING
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT THERE
BEEN SOME BUMPS IN THE ROAD- AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND- SO MANY OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN RESOLVED AND SO
IT'S NOT SURPRISING ALSO
APPEARED- TODAY THAT THERE ARE
STILL ISSUES SAID THAT THAT
REQUIRE. A RESOLUTION-
OBSTACLES. ARE THERE FOR US TO
SOLVE. AND I HAVE. WE WILL FIND
TO AS WE MOVE FOR THE RIGHT
PROPER A PATHWAY AROUND THOSE
OBSTACLES SO THAT- THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MOVEMENT- AND-
DISCIPLINE CAN FLOURISH IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- CEASELESS AND CONSTANT
SUPPORT OF ETHNIC STUDIES. THANK
YOU. N. AND NOW I WILL GO TO THE
PHONES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE
WILL AGAIN LIMIT PUBLIC COMMENT
TO TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE WHO WHO CAME IN PERSON
. SO TO THE PHONES- IF WE HAVE A
MODERATOR COULD WE GO TO THE
PHONES AND SEE WE HAVE ANY
ANYONE WAITING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO.
HEY WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS NICOLE YANG AND I AM
THE CHAPTER CHAIR FOR PATRICK
COUNTY MOM COOPER MCCARTY AND
I'M ALSO A MEXICAN AMERICAN. AND
I FEEL LIKE I'VE LISTENED TO THE
TESTIMONY. AND AS A MEXICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN I KNOW WHERE I
CAME FROM I KNOW MY ROOTS AND I
KNOW MY CONTRIBUTION TO SOCIETY
I ALSO SEE THE DISMAL STATE OF
AFFAIRS THAT IS THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE
WE'RE- CURRENTLY RANKED LAST IN
EDUCATION. I ATTENDED SOME OF
THE WORST PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN SOME
OF THE WORST NEIGHBORHOODS IN
CALIFORNIA AND MY SCHOOL HIGH
SCHOOL DROP OUT RATE WITH FIFTY
PERCENT- WE WERE PREDOMINANTLY
MINORITIES. WE WERE NOT
GRADUATING BECAUSE OF LACK OF
ETHNIC STUDIES WE ARE NOT
GRADUATING BECAUSE WE HAD A LACK
OF QUALIFIED TEACHERS I THINK
THAT THE EDUCATE HIGHER
EDUCATION NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED
MORE ON PREPARING THE TEACHERS
TO EDUCATE TODAY'S YOUTH. AND
LAST ON RACIAL INEQUALITY WELL
THEY DO HAPPEN. THEY'RE NOT AT
THE FOREFRONT OF MOST CHILDREN'S
MINDS AND THEY'RE NOT HOLDING
CHILDREN BACK. AT I THINK THE
BEST EXAMPLE OF ETHNIC STUDIES
IS TO ACTUALLY BE ETHNIC PEOPLE
STUDYING WHICH COMES FROM
QUALIFIED TEACHERS. AND
EDUCATING CHILDREN ON THE BASICS
OF READING WRITING. ANALOGICAL
REASONING SKILLS AND IF WE HOLD
THE STANDARDS WITHOUT IN
THIRTEEN RACE AND ETHNICITY AND
ETHNIC STUDIES AND PICKING
CURRICULUM THAT THE CHILDREN.
THE CHILDREN ALL RIGHT THE
OCCASION WE WILL SEE MORE
TEACHERS WE WILL SEE MORE PEOPLE
IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION. SYSTEM
AND WEALTHY EQUALITY TRULY
QUALITY. NOT CAN YOU FAX YOUR
EQUITY FROM THE STATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD WELL I
WILL THANK THE STAFF EVERYONE
HERE ALL STAFF MY STEP FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION-
THE- PEOPLE CAME TO TESTIFY BOTH
IN PERSON AND- AND REMOTELY. AND
JUST WANT TO SAY IN CLOSING
THAT. A LOT OF WORK BEING DONE-
MOSTLY BY THE INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING YES YOU SEE. AIR
TEACHERS WHO ARE GOING TO GO
INTO OUR CLASSROOMS WHO WILL BE
TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES. BUT I
THINK THE OTHER MESSAGE THAT I
GOT WAS THAT. FORTUNATELY THE-
TEACHER CREDENTIALING HAS NOT
APPARENTLY EVEN GIVEN IT ENOUGH
THOUGHT TO HOW THEY ARE GOING TO
ENSURE. THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GONNA BE IN THE CLASSROOMS TO
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES ARE INDEED
QUALIFIED TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES SO THIS IS THE FIRST.
HEARING THAT I AM CONVENING ON
THIS TOPIC AND WE WILL CONVENE
ANOTHER HEARING AND HOPEFULLY AT
THAT TIME I WOULD SEE SOME
PROGRESS. ON THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND CAN COME
BACK SOME IDEAS OF IN WHAT
DIRECTION DO THEY WANT TO SEE-
CREDENTIALING GOING SO THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT ALL TEACHERS WHO
ARE IN THE CLASSROOM TEACHING
ETHNIC STUDIES. ARE INDEED
QUALIFIED TO TEACH THAT CLASS
AND WITH THAT WE ARE CAN BE. THE
JURY.